dahinter
beides wichtig Michael Saar und vielen
Dank und ja vereinbarte Debatte das ist
eine Aussprache hier im Plenum des
Deutschen Bundestags bei der ist keine
Vorlagen gibt also keine Anträge keine
Gesetzentwürfe keine Regierungserklärung
sondern wo vor allem Themen besprochen
werden die weitreichend sind oder
umfangreich und das ganze dann auch eher
grundsätzlich und genauso ist es heute
morgen zum Thema nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die hat sich
die Bundesrepublik die Bundesregierung
seit 2002 gegeben regelmäßig angepasst
seit 2015 ungefähr basiert sie auf der
Agenda 2030 der Vereinten Nationen und
deren Nachhaltigkeitszielen von denen es
eine ganze Menge gibt über die wir dann
im Laufe des Vormittags auch eine ganze
Menge hören werden und es geht nicht nur
wie man meinen könnte um Natur Umwelt
oder Klimaschutz sondern es geht auch um
globale Verantwortung dabei um sozialen
Zusammenhalt oder auch um Bildung
Wissenschaft und Innovation also ein in
der Tat sehr weitreichendes Feld und
deswegen wollen wir das ein bisschen
aufdröseln ein bisschen Hintergrund auch
liefern worum es dann in den nächsten
drei Stunden hier im Parlament gehen
wird und ich freue mich dass bei uns in
Tessa gansera die Obfrau ist im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung auch ein Gremium das uns
nicht ganz so präsent ist und Wolfgang
stiefinger ist bei uns der ist der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende eben dieses
Gremiums Frau ganzer sie sind
diplom-ingenieuren für Wald und
Forstwirtschaft wir wissen dass
Nachhaltigkeit aus dem Forstwirtschaft
kommt aus wie diesem Sektor und trotzdem
wird es übertragen auch auf andere
Bereiche das ist beim Thema Wirtschaft
noch einigermaßen nachvollziehbar Wurf
ist Nachhaltigkeit aber beispielsweise
bei Bildung oder bei Wissenschaft nun
mit der nachhaltigen Entwicklung der
verfolgen wir kein geringeres Ziel als
das alle Menschen auf dieser Erde ein
gutes Leben in Würde ermöglicht wird und
das auch unseren künftigen Generationen
unseren Enkeln und urenkelkindern und
dazu müssen wir unsere ganze Lebens- und
Wirtschaftsweise so gestalten dass wir
die globalen Grenzen die ökologischen
Grenzen auch einhalten und soll großes
Ziel erreicht man natürlich nicht mit
einem Debatte mit einem Beschluss der
Klasse dafür braucht sie langfristige
Strategie der Punkt den ich meinte war
wenn man auf die auf die Wälder guckt
auf die Nutzung von Wäldern wo der
Begriff wie gesagt herkommt irgendwie
das nur so viel Bäume geschlagen werden
wie man auch wieder neu anpflanzen kann
also dass er ein gewisses Gleichgewicht
bleibt wie muss ich mir dieses
übertragen vorstellen auf die Bereiche
Bildung oder Wissenschaft das war der
Punkt gerade bildung ist der Schlüssel
auch zur gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe zum
guten Leben und deswegen sind natürlich
bei diesem Ziel eine nachhaltigen
Entwicklung dass alle Menschen nur gutes
Leben führen können auch solche Themen
wie Geschlechtergerechtigkeit und
Bildung hier in Deutschland aber auch
globaler ganz wichtiges Anliegen den
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung gibt es seit
hier schildern sozusagen ein bisschen
der stehfinger was das Gremium macht es
hat ja haben wir gelesen in der
Vorbereitung eine sogenannte
wach-funktion erläutern Sie das mal ein
bisschen
ja vielen Dank für die Frage ist es so
dass dieser parlamentarische Beirat eben
gegründet wurde um auch eine
Aufsichtsfunktion des Parlamentes
gegenüber der Bundesregierung zu haben
das Parlament korrigiert ja und auch
kontrolliert auch die Regierung und
deswegen sind alle Gesetze auch hier in
dem parlamentarischen Beirat
mitzuüberprüfen ob die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele eben eingesetzt und
eingehalten werden von der
Bundesregierung und dafür gibt es diesen
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung wir von der Union hätten ihn
gerne als ordentlichen Ausschuss gehabt
das hat die neue Mehrheit im Parlament
nicht mitgemacht aber ich denke auch so
wird dieser Beirat seiner Funktion
gerecht um einfach die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele wirklich in den
Gesetzgebungen auch zu überprüfen sagen
Sie mal konkret wo sie dann tatsächlich
täglich geworden sind bislang in dieser
Wahlperiode das sind natürlich Themen
jetzt bei der Energieversorgung
beispielsweise das sind Themen Mobilität
also die unterschiedlichsten Bereiche
wenn sie sich die 17
Nachhaltigkeitsziele anschauen
wir haben selber schon angesprochen
Bildung Forschung ob das Entwicklung ist
ob das Wasserversorgung ist
Umweltschutz wirtschaftliche Themen also
wirklich es gibt im Endeffekt kaum ein
Gesetzesvorhaben dass der
parlamentarische Beirat nicht auch mit
begleiten muss weil es eben immer um
dieses große Thema Nachhaltigkeit geht
Nachhaltigkeitsziele hat sie
Bundesregierung seit 2002 gesetzt warum
sind wir nicht weiter heute im Jahr 2022
nun ich denke es ist erst einmal wichtig
positiv herauszuheben dass wir seit 2002
diese Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie haben und
dass alle Bundesregierungen über die
verschiedensten parteipolitischen
Farbspiele hinweg an dieser
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie festgehalten
haben und die auch weiterentwickelt
solche großen Ziele erreichen auch nicht
von heute auf morgen deswegen muss er
immer wieder überprüft werden was immer
und dann falls sie eben auch nach
Steuern und gerade jetzt auch die
letzten Jahre die corona-pandemie jetzt
dieser bürgerliche Angriffskrieg stellte
Politik immer wieder vor neuen
Herausforderungen auf die kurzfristig
Antworten gefunden werden müssen und
deswegen braucht es auch immer wieder
über Prüfung ich glaube langfristig
müssen wir dahin gehen dass wir diese
nachhaltigkeitsüberprüfung der Gesetze
noch mal sehr verstellen also hört sich
ein bisschen so an als wenn Sie
zufrieden mit dem Stand der Dinge kann
mir nicht also zufällig mir nicht
vorstellen kann man nicht sein wenn wir
uns denn die katoren anschauen in
Deutschland aber auch global dann sind
wir noch meilenweit davon entfernt diese
Nachhaltigkeitsziele einzuhalten zu
erreichen und deswegen brauchen wir da
auch noch mal kräftigere Anstrengungen
ich halte wichtig dass wir wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart bei der
gesetzesfolgen Abschätzung noch mal ganz
genau und viel genauer hinschauen
vielleicht dann nochmal Zielkonflikte
deutlich aufmachen und frühzeitig zu
erkennen wenn es in die falsche angeht
oder wenn man nicht schnell genug
vorwärts kommen warum Herr stefinger
sind wir nicht weiter dieselbe Frage
auch an sie ich würde das gar nicht zu
Problemen
also ich würde es gar nicht so negativ
sehen weil wenn wir uns insgesamt die
Situation anschauen wir waren schon auf
einem sehr guten Weg wenn ich jetzt auch
als entwicklungspolitiker sagen darf
auch das Ziel eine Welt ohne Hunger das
waren ambitioniertes Ziel bis 2030 ob
wir es geschafft hätten ich glaube wir
hätten es vielleicht knapp hinbekommen
wäre Corona nicht gekommen also solche
Punkte glaube ich muss man schon auch
sehen wenn wir auch anschauen weltweit
global wie sich auch die
Sterblichkeit bei Frauen verringert hat
Geburten nach Geburten beispielsweise
all diese Themen sind auch alle mit in
der Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie drin da
waren wir und sind wir auch auf einem
sehr sehr guten Weg wir haben natürlich
es auch immer wieder mit Rückschlägen zu
tun das darf man auch nicht
wegdiskutieren aber wir waren und sind
auf einem guten Weg und man darf diese
Anstrengungen halt nicht nachlassen das
ist jetzt das große Thema auch gerade
auch im Entwicklungsbereich ich kann nur
immer wieder auch sagen
Entwicklungspolitik ist globale
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik und wir müssen
alle Themen auch global denken wir
dürfen nicht die Sicht auch beim Klima
nicht die Sicht alleine auf Deutschland
verengen oder auf Europa wir müssen auch
die wachsenden Regionen dieser Erde
anschauen und da kommen wir an Afrika
nicht vorbei alleine wenn wir das
Bevölkerungswachstum anscheinend alleine
wenn wir überlegen dass auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent 600 Millionen
Menschen keinen Zugang zu einer
Steckdose haben diesen aber auch haben
wollen also sehen wir alleine schon wie
auch hier der Bedarf zu decken ist und
deswegen ist Entwicklungspolitik
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik wenn ich selber
richtig verstehe würden Sie dann die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele die die Ampel im
Koalitionsvertrag zumindest genannt und
aufgelistet hatte im Prinzip dann auch
zustimmen es sind viele wichtige Punkte
dabei auf die wir uns ja auch schon
lange gemeinsam international
verständigt haben die im
Koalitionsvertrag ist ja nichts neues
drin das sind die die sdgs also die die
nachhaltigkeits die noch mal
ausformuliert wurden und das Wichtige
ist aber nochmal dass wir die Sicht
nicht verengen und deswegen verstehe ich
beispielsweise nicht warum die Ampel
massiv im entwicklungsetat kürzt weil
das ist eigentlich der zukunftsetat
gerade was die Nachhaltigkeit betrifft
Frau doch direkt mal nach
vor
also ich
will das jetzt nicht beschönigen wir
brauchen natürlich auch international
mehr Anstrengungen und zwar in allen
Bereichen nicht nur in einzelnen wir
brauchen denke ich global mehr
Anstrengungen beim internationalen
Klimaschutz weil das ist eine eine Krise
die die uns immer stärker auch betrifft
und hier hat Deutschland ganz große
Verantwortung und da haben wir in
Koalitionsvertrag auch in den letzten
Monaten da ganze Reihe am Paketen auf
dem Weg gebracht und diese Ziele auch zu
erreichen ich will trotzdem noch mal auf
die Relevanz unter die Bedeutung der
dieses parlamentarischen Beirats zurück
sie haben schon angedeutet dass sie sich
da mehr wünschen trotzdem gibt es keine
bzw wie sehen dann die Empfehlungen ganz
konkret aus im Gesetzgebungsverfahren
auf der einen Seite den der Bericht zu
den Nachhaltigkeitszielen der kommt ja
von der Bundesregierung und nicht aus
diesem nicht aus diesem Beirat wieso
eigentlich nicht
also der parlamentarische Beirat haben
in den letzten Jahren sehr viele gute
Denkanstöße gebracht auch das Thema
sustandable also nachhaltige Finanzen
war so ein Thema das der peirat auf dem
Weg gebracht hat wir begleiten auch den
staatssekretärsausschuss für nachhaltige
Entwicklung wo wir im Vorbereitung auf
diese Sitzungen auf unsere eigenen
Positionspapiere erarbeiten können
einspeisen können und damit auch
Einfluss auf die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik der
Bundesregierung nehmen können also ich
würde einfach ergänzen ja dass wir
wirklich auktionsfeier angesprochen
diese wach und Funktion haben und eben
dann auch wenn wir sehen das läuft in
die falsche Richtung dann auch wirklich
laut bellen so wie das ein Wachhund am
Ende des Tages auch machen sollte aber
man kriegt es in der Öffentlichkeit
nicht wirklich richtig mit ne
heute ist ein guter Anfang dass wir
vielleicht machen wir das öfter und
können dann auch über dieses Thema
diskutieren wofür es am meisten Frau
ganze über was sie Nachhaltigkeit angeht
in welchem sektorverkehr Landwirtschaft
Bildung also Herr stefinger hat ja schon
Entwicklungspolitik angesprochen dürfen
den einen Bereich nicht gegen den
anderen Ausspielen des soziale
Gerechtigkeit der Zugang zu Bildung ist
genauso wichtiges Anliegen für gutes
Leben für alle Menschen wie der
Klimaschutz und deswegen müssen wir
überall dort wo wir noch Defizite haben
unsere Kraftanstrengungen nochmal
erhöhen die haben schon der den Einfluss
der Pandemie eben angesprochen welche
frage ich noch mal andersrum ich will
die gar nicht will die gar nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen aber welcher
Weg ist im Moment der Stein nicht so
formuliere ich mal so oder welcher
Bereich ist der schwierigste ich glaube
das gerade keine einfaches also gerade
jetzt diese fürchterliche Angriffskrieg
der von Putin auch mit Getreide mit
Nahrungsmitteln und mit hungern geführt
hat für uns natürlich bei Ziel den
Hunger in dieser Welt zu reduzieren
nochmal vor viel größeren
Herausforderungen wir haben einmal das
Thema Klimaschutz dass man genauso wenig
aus den Augen verlieren dürfen wie den
Erhalt der natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
weil eben auch der Verlust der
Artenvielfalt
massive Auswirkungen auf stabile
Ökosysteme die die Grundlage für unser
ganzes Leben sind haben und deswegen
müssen wir in allen Bereichen tätig
werden Nachhaltigkeit das ist genau der
Punkt den ich denke auf den ich jetzt
auch noch mal kommen wollte ist im
Grunde ja eine Querschnittsaufgabe es
geht ist ressortübergreifend wird wir
haben es eben auch schon gehört im
Kanzleramt im Großen und Ganzen
koordiniert ist das dadurch dass es so
eine Querschnittsaufgabe ist auch schon
mein Problem an sich um um auch an
einzelne Punkte besser ranzukommen das
sehe ich nicht es ist einfach so wie bei
Digitalisierung auch es ist einfach ein
Thema das alle aber das hängt sehr auch
alle Bereiche betrifft und von daher das
Wichtige ist glaube ich wirklich wenn
wir uns auf diese sdg-ziele
lebendigen auf die Nachhaltigkeitsziele
das dann auch jedes Ministerium jede
Behörde eben auch in dem eigenen Beritt
in dem eigenen Bereich eben auch schauen
muss dass diese Ziele auch eingehalten
sind darum geht es auch es geht auch
darum ein gewisses Bewusstsein zu
schaffen am Ende ist die Politik kann
auch oft nur Rahmenbedingungen geben am
Ende hängt auch an unseren allen an den
Verbrauchern an einen Konsumenten und da
gehören auch die Behörden die Exekutive
mit dazu dass man auch hier drüber
nachdenkt und sich auch frägt wie
nachhaltig sind wir auch in unserem
eigenen Handeln wie klimaneutrales der
Bundestag sind die Behörden
beispielsweise die die Landesministerien
all diese Themen spielen dann natürlich
mit entscheidende Rolle und ich glaube
es geht auch um Bewusstsein Schwerpunkt
das sind ihre Erwartungen eine Debatte
nachher um 9 Uhr jetzt gleich in zwei
drei Minuten also ich hoffe und wir
wünschen dass wir uns nicht im
parteipolitischen kleinen
zerreltern sondern wirklich die
Gemeinsamkeiten herausarbeiten und das
heißt an dieser Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
festhalten die weiter fortschreiben das
Thema
mehr Bedeutung im Deutschen Bundestag zu
verleihen und auch zu erkennen dass mir
ressortübergreifend arbeiten müssen und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr
Ehrlichkeit in der Debatte das Leben ist
nicht schwarz-weiß macht man gibt es
heute Zielkonflikte und die glaube ich
muss mal offen machen dass man dann auch
erkennt wenn man sich für einen eine
Richtung entscheidet um bestimmte Ziele
der nachhaltigen Entwicklung zu
erreichen das ist Konflikte in anderen
Bereichen gibt aber wenn man das offen
transparent macht dann wird aber auch
deutlich dass man diesen Bereichen in
Zukunft noch mehr Kraftanstrengung
braucht und das würde ich mir wünschen
mehr Ehrlichkeit und wirklich die Themen
vernetzt denken hätte ich eine Chance in
einer vereinbarten Debatte heute
irgendwie wo man sich nicht um einzelne
Anträge streiten muss und sind ihre
Erwartungen also meine Erwartung ist
dass wir wirklich das Thema offen
miteinander diskutieren ich darf aber
schon auch eins sagen dass ich sehr
bedauerlich finde dass die jetzige
Regierung die debattenzeit auf drei
Stunden reduz hat die Union hat in der
letzten Wahlperiode eine ganze Woche
Nachhaltigkeit gemacht und das finde ich
schon sehr sehr schade dass gerade eine
Regierung und der Beteiligung der Grünen
nur noch drei Stunden Zeit findet um
über dieses wichtige Thema zu
diskutieren und auch das könnte ein
Thema werden in der Debatte Frau gansera
vielen Dank dass Sie heute morgen bei
uns gewesen sind auch Ihnen Herr
stefinger herzlichen Dank sie dürfen
jetzt auch reingehen wird doch jetzt
noch ein bisschen knapp oder ein
bisschen knapper als ich gehofft hatte
aber das macht nichts wir haben wichtige
Punkte besprochen im Vorfeld dieser
Debatte die jetzt hier gleich beginnt
vielen dank Ihnen und wir schauen hinein
in den Plenarsaal des Deutschen
Bundestages der schon recht gut gefüllt
ist alles andere wäre auch nicht
wirklich gut wir hören im Hintergrund
den Gong auch das ist ein gutes Zeichen
denn das bedeutet dass die
Bundestagspräsidentin auf dem Weg zu
ihrem Platz ist was wir jetzt auch sehen
und das bedeutet ich gebe direkt hinein
in den Plenarsaal und wir stehen vor
drei Stunden Debatte zur nationalen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
allen einen schönen guten Morgen die
Sitzung ist eröffnet
Entschuldigung
zunächst gratuliere ich dem Kollegen
Alexander Engelhardt nachträglich zu
seinem 50 Geburtstag und wünsche Ihnen
Namen des ganzen Hauses alles Gute zum
neuen Lebensjahr
dann müssen wir noch einige Wahlen
durchführen als Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
zur Parlamentarischen Versammlung des
Europarates sollen auf Vorschlag der
Fraktion
cdu/csu die Abgeordneten Katharina dos
Santos Vince als Nachfolgerin für die
Abgeordnete Sabine weiß als ordentliches
Mitglied der Abgeordnete Jürgen hart als
persönliches
stellvertretendes Mitglied für die
Abgeordnete Katharina dos Santos Vince
und die Abgeordnete dr Katja leikert als
Nachfolgerin für den bisher von Jürgen
hart übernommenen persönliche
Stellvertretung gewählt werden
ich sehe sie sind damit einverstanden
dann ist das so der Fall damit sind die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gewählt
[Applaus]
zudem soll in den Beirat der
Schlichtungsstelle für den öffentlichen
Personen Verkehr auf Vorschlag der
Fraktion der SPD der Abgeordnete Jan
plobner als Nachfolger für die
ausgeschiedene Abgeordnete Bela Bach für
die restliche Amtszeit gewählt werden
ich sehe auch damit sind Sie
einverstanden damit ist der Kollege Jan
plöbner als Mitglied gewählt außerdem
soll auf Vorschlag der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen die Abgeordnete
aue-test verjesus in den Stiftungsrat
der Stiftung Orte der Deutschen
demokratiegeschichte als ordentliches
Mitglied gewählt werden auch damit sind
Sie einverstanden das ist der Fall dann
ist die Kollegin als Mitglied gewählt
[Applaus]
ich komme nun zur Tagesordnung aufgrund
der gestern auf Verlangen der Fraktion
der AFD gemäß Anlage 5 Nummer 1
Buchstabe b der Geschäftsordnung
durchgeführten Aktuellen Stunde aus der
Fragestunde wird die aktuelle Stunde zu
den Protesten im Iran nach dem Tod von
marshainer Amini in
Polizeigewahrsam heute im Anschluss an
die ohne debattenpunkte aufgerufen am
Freitag soll der Tagesordnungspunkt 24
abgesetzt
und an diese Stelle als Zusatzpunkt ein
Bericht des Wirtschaftsausschusses nach
§ 62 Absatz 2 der Geschäftsordnung auf
Drucksache
3740 aufgerufen werden als letzter Punkt
am Freitag ist eine Aktuelle Stunde mit
dem Titel Deutschland ein Jahr nach der
Bundestagswahl Zeit für Klarheit und
Führung vorgesehen
sind Sie damit einverstanden ich sehe
keinen Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 7
vereinbarte Debatte zu den sechs
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
180 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die Bundesregierung die
Bundesministerin für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung Svenja
Schulze und ich freue mich Ihr heute
auch zu ihrem Geburtstag gratulieren zu
können herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren es geht hier heute um
Nachhaltigkeit und zwar um
Nachhaltigkeit als Richtschnur der
deutschen Politik und die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die liegt dafür
quasi den roten Faden fest das ist die
konkrete Umsetzung der Agenda 2030 der
Vereinten Nationen und das Gute an
dieser Strategie ist die Macht Erfolge
sichtbar aber sie zeigt auch sehr klar
wo die Herausforderungen am größten sind
und wo wir besser werden müssen das ist
so eine Strategie in dieser Art und
Weise gibt das ist wirklich weltweit
beispielgegend
die soziale und ökologische
Transformation ist ein ganz zentraler
Baustein für nachhaltige Entwicklung
aber auch das steht vor großen
Herausforderungen wir haben es hier im
Parlament diskutiert globale Krisen der
Klimawandel die corona-pandemie die
Auswirkung des angriffskriegs von
Russland auf die Ukraine das alles
verstärkt sich gegenseitig und bringt
auch das was wir an Fortschritt schon
erreicht haben inzwischen wieder ins
Stocken und es zeigt sich deutlicher
denn je wir müssen
gemeinschaftlich Handeln Solidarität ist
der Schlüssel zur Umsetzung der Agenda
2030 und es geht darum ein besseres
Leben für alle Menschen auf der Welt zu
organisieren ohne dass wir dabei unseren
Planeten ruinieren
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger können nicht
mehr alleine mit nationalen Gesetzen vor
den Folgen des globalen Klimawandels
geschützt werden unsere
Ernährungssicherheit unsere
Energieversorgung unserer
Arbeitsbedingungen unsere Zukunft hängt
davon ab dass wir gemeinsam als
internationale Gemeinschaft hier
Lösungen schaffen und das heißt im
Umkehrschluss nachhaltige Entwicklung
ist nur dann in Deutschland möglich wenn
wir uns global dafür einsetzen und das
umfasst drei Ebenen in Deutschland durch
Deutschland in multilateralen Bündnissen
und wird Deutschland in bilateraler
Zusammenarbeit mit unseren Partnern und
genau das treibt dort die deutsche
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit voran durch
internationale Allianzen und
Kooperationen mit Zivilgesellschaft
Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft trägt das
Entwicklungsministerium weltweit zu
strukturellen Veränderungen bei und wir
arbeiten gemeinsam mit den
Partnerländern an Lösungen für die
dringendsten Herausforderungen
und dazu gehört ohne Zweifel die
Transformation hin zur Klimaneutralität
wir brauchen eine globale Energiewende
bei der Gerechte Übergänge und gute
Arbeit sichergestellt wird dafür ist
international der Begriff just
transition gefunden worden es ist keine
Frage bei eine klimagerechte Wirtschaft
bei steigendem Energiebedarf zu schaffen
das ist ein immenser Kraftakt das gilt
hier für uns in Deutschland das gilt
aber noch mehr für unsere Partnerländer
und mir ist wichtig dass wir diesen
Übergang zu Klimaneutralität sozial
gerecht gestalten Klimaschutz gelingt
nur mit sozialer Sicherheit
ganz konkret bedeutet das dass wir als
dass ich als entwicklungsministerin
unser Engagement für saubere und für
sichere energieausbauern werden um eine
sichere Zukunft für alle Menschen zu
ermöglichen wir unterstützen unsere
Partnerländer dabei gute klimagerechte
Beschäftigung zu schaffen und
leistungsfähige soziale
Sicherungssysteme zu stärken wir treiben
eine sozialökologische Transformation
der Wirtschaft und eine nachhaltige
Umgestaltung der Finanzwirtschaft voran
und wir helfen armen Länder dabei sich
besser an den Klimawandel anzupassen die
Artenvielfalt die natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen von uns allen zu
schützen und wir setzen uns dafür ein
Städte klimagerechter mit lebenswerten
Wohnraum für alle Menschen zu machen ein
Beispiel wie das funktioniert sind die
just energy transition partnerships wie
wir sie im Rahmen der G7 mit Südafrika
auf dem Weg gebracht haben oder die
bilateralen Partnerschaften ich war ja
bereits in Ländern wie zum Beispiel
Ruanda oder auch indien ist einer der
Partner die Cote Diva mit dem wir solche
Partnerschaften anstoßen im Rahmen
dieser Partnerschaft unterstützen wir
dann die Länder beim Kohleausstieg und
dem Aufbau von alternativer
Energiegewinnung und dabei gilt es dann
sozial gerechte Strukturen aufzubauen
die dann auch wirklich alle Beteiligten
einbeziehen so können dann wirklich
lokale Wertschöpfung
Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten qualifizierte
Arbeitsplätze in einer zukunftsindustrie
geschaffen werden und das macht die
Länder schrittweise unabhängiger von
fossilen energiequälen Quellen von
einseitigen Lieferbeziehungen und es
können darüber hinaus noch exporterlöser
erzielt werden das ist ein Gewinn für
soziale Gerechtigkeit und für
Klimaschutz Instrumente wie diese
energiepartnerschaften tragen direkt zu
den Prinzipien der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie bei es gilt
jetzt die nötigen Investitionen zu
tätigen es geht jetzt die weich
vorstellen für widerstandsfähige und
nachhaltiges Gesellschaften weltweit
sozial gerechte Gesellschaften in denen
eine gleichberechtigte Teilhabe am
politischen am wirtschaftlichen Leben
für alle Menschen möglich ist und zwar
nicht nur weil das gerecht ist sondern
auch weil die Ergebnisse dann deutlich
besser sind kurz gesagt Deutschland
nimmt seine internationale Verantwortung
war die Bundesregierung setzt sich für
eine soziale wirtschaftliche und
ökologische Entwicklung ein in
Deutschland und weltweit nicht trotz der
vielen Herausforderung sondern weil
diese gezeigt haben das globale Krisen
nur global gelöst werden können
Klimawandel Pandemie Konflikte und
Kriege dürfen nicht gegeneinander
ausgespielt werden sondern ihre Ursachen
müssen gleichzeitig angegangen werden
wer denn je ist es notwendig die Ziele
der Agenda 2030 als internationale
Gemeinschaft zu erreichen das von Zielen
das beschließen von Maßnahmen ist dabei
nicht genug wir müssen unsere
Anstrengung verstärken um grundlegende
strukturelle Veränderungen zu erwirken
und zwar jetzt die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie da muss dazu
dazu wirksam und verbindlich beitragen
und das tut sie herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Felix schreiner
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Frau Bundesministerin Schulze auch von
unserer Fraktion gratulieren wir Ihnen
sehr herzlich zu ihrem Geburtstag wenn
wir heute zur Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte im
Deutschen Bundestag zusammenkommen da
lassen uns die furchtbaren Bilder von
dem blutigen Krieg in der Ukraine
natürlich nicht kalt wir sehen jeden Tag
und es wird uns jeden Tag aufs Neue
bewusst dass sich unsere Tagesordnung
geändert hat und wir im Deutschen
Bundestag über Maßnahmen entscheiden
müssen die wir uns alle vor einem Jahr
noch nicht hätten vorstellen können
Inflation Ukraine Krieg steigender Zins
das sind die Realitäten mit denen wir
uns zu beschäftigen haben und deshalb
sind die Debatten die wir mit denen wir
die Menschen in unserem Land die
heimischen Betriebe entlasten richtig
und trotz oder gerade wegen diesem
Themen diesen Herausforderungen ist es
aber heute auch wichtig dass wir
langfristige nicht aus dem Blick
verlieren und sie ganz bewusst in den
Mittelpunkt in der Debatte hier im
Deutschen Bundestag stellen
der Dreiklang aus Ökologie aus Ökonomie
und Soziales er muss auch in
Krisenzeiten nachhaltig miteinander im
Einklang gebracht werden weil zur
Wahrheit gehört wie erleben einen
Klimawandel die Zerstörung von
Lebensräumen und einen fast
unersätlichen
Ressourcenhunger aber gleichzeitig
stellen wir auch fest dass fast alle
Regierungen in der Welt eine Abkehr von
solider und generationengerechter
Haushalts- und Finanzpolitik zeigen
lassen Sie uns also in dieser Debatte zu
Beginn und selbst fragen warum wir zu
sehr an das heute denken und für das
heute leben warum unser Land so sehr von
der Substanz zehrt und warum so wenig an
das morgen gedacht wird wir müssen
unsere Verhaltensweisen selbst in Frage
stellen das muss am Anfang aller
Bemühungen stehen wenn wir es ernst mein
mit der Nachhaltigkeit in diesem Land
und wir müssen lernen wie wir gerade in
Krisenzeiten Politik wieder stärker vom
Ende Hering das beste Beispiel dafür ist
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse 2014
auf den Weg gebracht hat sie die erste
schwarze Null seit 45 Jahren geebnet es
ist
es ist nicht akzeptabel wenn wir auf
Kosten künftiger Generationen leben und
ihnen einen Schuldenberg hinterlassen
den diese Generationen nie mehr abtragen
können auch das gehört zur Wahrheit am
heutigen Tag
und soweit gehören auch dass wir uns
auch wie in den vergangenen Jahren eine
nachhaltigkeitswoche gewünscht hätten
dass wir eine nachhaltigkeitswoche im
Deutschen Bundestag durchführen wie es
auf Antrag der Unionsfraktion 2020 der
Fall war die neue Mehrheit in diesem
Haus hat die Auffassung vertreten dass
eine dreistündige Debatte reicht drei
Stunden für dieses Thema kann das ihr
Ernst sein
gut also jeder blamiert sich selbst auf
dem besten wir es kann sie haben gehört
der AFD eine Stunde gereicht weil sie
dieses Thema nicht ernst nehmen können
wir Sie bei diesem Thema auch schon gar
nicht ernst nehmen das gehört auch zur
Wahrheit dazu
ich finde es auch bedauerlich dass wir
kein gemeinsamen Antrag vorgelegt haben
so wie das früher immer der Fall war wir
haben einen Antrag ausgearbeitet als
Unionsfraktion wir bringen Ihnen heute
wir legen ihn heute vor sie können in ja
gerne mit unterstützen aber sie haben es
gar nicht zugelassen dass wir über
Anträge auch debattieren und um die
nachhaltige Entwicklung krisenfester zu
machen müssen wir auch über kurzfristige
Maßnahmen in vielen Bereichen sprechen
und sie anstoßen wir fordern die
Bundesregierung deshalb auf
schnellstmöglich wieder zu einer soliden
Finanzpolitik zurückzukehren und die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und sagen Sie
eine klare Absage an alle in ihrer
Koalition die in Wahrheit ja nur darauf
warten die Schuldenbremse endlich außer
Kraft zu setzen das ist nicht unser Weg
das ist mit der Union nicht zu machen
wir müssen unsere Infrastruktur Stärken
dabei geht es nicht nur um den Bereich
Verkehr es geht auch um Energie um
Wasser es geht um Abwasser es geht um
Breitband es geht um die Luftreinhaltung
und es geht um die Abfallwirtschaft ich
sage es in aller Deutlichkeit es hat
auch mit Nachhaltigkeit nichts zu tun
wenn die ampelregierung das erfolgreiche
Programm
investitionspakt Sportstätten nicht
weiterführt hört sich als kleines
Projekt an ist aber in Wahrheit der
gerannt dafür für viele Städte und
Kommunen dass eine gut ausgebaute
öffentliche eine nachhaltige
Infrastruktur in den Städten ermöglicht
wird auch das gehört zur Wahrheit sie
kürzen solche Programme weil sie ihn
nicht in den Kram passen
ein weiterer Punkt ist für uns die
Sicherstellung der Ernährung wir müssen
die regionalen Produkte stärken die
Produktion stärken aber wir müssen auch
die Vielfalt von Nutzpflanzen erhalten
und die Züchtung von klimaresilienten
Sorten fördern wir alle erleben dass wir
viel besser werden müssen wenn wir die
Rahmenbedingungen anschauen wie die
Verschwendung von Lebensmittel besser
abgebaut werden kann auch da setzen wir
auf die Nutzung von Möglichkeiten von
digitalen Technologien es kann nicht
sein dass in diesem Land das so reich
ist immer noch so viele Lebensmittel Tag
für Tag verschwendet und weggeschmissen
werden
und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn
nicht den Deutschen Bundestag wo es denn
dann eigentlich der richtige Ort über
Debatten von einem über ein gutes Morgen
und darüber zu führen wie wir uns
gemeinsam überlegen wie wir diese langen
Linien in die Tagespolitik auch umsetzen
können wir Abgeordnete haben es doch
selbst in der Hand wir können doch
entscheiden ob wir das Thema
Nachhaltigkeit auf die Agenda setzen
oder wir entscheiden darüber ob es eben
nur ein Randthema ist und wir der
Regierung zuschauen ob sie die 17
sdg-ziele einführt oder umsetzt oder
nicht aber es kann doch nicht unser
Anspruch als Parlamentarier im Deutschen
Bundestag sein dass wir dieses Thema
nicht in den Mittelpunkt der Debatte
setzen Nachhaltigkeit darf keine Floskel
sein nachhaltigkeit ist eine Frage der
politischen Überzeugung es ist aber auch
eine Frage der politischen Haltung meine
Damen und Herren und auch deshalb
diskutieren wir heute diese Debatte mit
ihnen aus ganzer Überzeugung herzlichen
Dank
Felix Schreiner aus der Unionsfraktion
Obmann im parlamentarischen Beirat für
nachhaltige Entwicklung kritisierte die
Dauer der Debatte und zwar als zu kurz
und der verweist zu Recht darauf dass in
der vergangenen Legislaturperiode an
mehreren Tagen und auch zu den
jeweiligen Ressorts über Nachhaltigkeit
debattiert wurde hier im Deutschen
Bundestag nächste Rednerin Bettina
Hoffmann stellt Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin beim der bei der
Ministerin für Umwelt Naturschutz und
nukleare Sicherheit
wir alle wissen aber was wir eigentlich
brauchen sind 52 Wochen der
Nachhaltigkeit im Jahr wir stecken tief
in einer globalen nachhaltigkeitskrise
Artensterben Klimakrise und
Umweltvergiftungen Vermüllung das sind
Symptome Folge sind auch Flucht vieler
Menschen und am Ende Kriege um Rohstoffe
und um Land es liegt in unser aller
Verantwortung wir müssen und können die
großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
bewältigen dafür müssen wir unsere
Anstrengung aber deutlich verstärken und
das ist der Ziel der das Ziel der
Bundesregierung
doch die Wirklichkeit die Wirklichkeit
holt uns ein die roten Linien unserer
planetaren Grenzen sind bereits
überschritten unsere natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen sind mehr denn je in
Gefahr das Pariser Abkommen 2015 war
sicher ein historisches Ereignis erst
recht unter dem heutigen Blickwinkel
aber der weltweite
treibhausausstoß ist seitdem nicht
gesunken Hitze Dürre und Hochwasser und
Extremwetter gibt es immer häufiger das
Arten aussterben ist nicht gestoppt ganz
im Gegenteil die weltweite Verschmutzung
von Umwelt und Ozean mit Plastik und
Schadstoffen nimmt immer größere Ausmaße
an die covid 19-pandemie hat uns immer
noch im Griff weitere Pandemien stehen
vor der Tür und jetzt noch der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
er ist auch ein Angriff auf die mit der
Weltgemeinschaft vereinbarten
Nachhaltigkeitsziele von der Verletzung
Menschenrechte über den Einsatz von
Lebensmitteln und Energielieferungen als
erpresserische Waffe bis hin zum
Abfackeln von Erdgas zu Lasten von Klima
und Umwelt
die großen Krisen unserer Zeit fordern
uns wirklich heraus aber es muss
spätestens jetzt allen klar sein wir
müssen schneller komplexer und
international abgestimmter agieren nicht
ein Problem nach dem anderen lösen
sondern ihr umfassend im Sinne aller 17
sdgs
leider deswegen uns heute noch die
Fehler der Vergangenheit
Kohlekraftwerke aus der Reserve zu holen
lng-lieferungen zu organisieren und
sogar die letzten Atomkraftwerke über
den Winter in Bereitschaft zu halten
gegen alle Regeln der Nachhaltigkeit das
ist bitter aber wir lassen uns nicht
beirren mit Energieeffizienz Energie
einsparen und einen beherzten Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren gehen wir voran und holen
unser Land aus der Abhängigkeit von
fossilen Energien wir sorgen dafür
das niemand in Energiearmut fällt oder
Strom und gassperren ausgesetzt das wir
schützen Unternehmen und Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern vor explodierenden Preise das
stärkt den Zusammenhalt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Bundesregierung ist angetreten als
zukunftsbündnis für Freiheit
Gerechtigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit wir
nehmen die internationale Verantwortung
wahr und bringen die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik auch in
Deutschland voran trotz oder gerade
wegen der großen Herausforderung wir
konzentrieren uns auf sechs wichtige
transformationsfelder ich will das an
zwei Beispielen deutlich machen erstens
am transformationsfeld
Kreislaufwirtschaft ungefähr die Hälfte
aller globalen Treibhausgasemissionen
und 90 Prozent das atemaussterbens und
auch die Wasserknappheit sind auf die
Gewinnung und Verarbeitung von
Rohstoffen zurückzuführen es deshalb
darum mit unseren Ressourcen möglichst
schonend umzugehen sie sparsam
einzusetzen und solange sie möglich im
Kreislauf zu halten die Bundesregierung
hat sich daher das Ziel gesetzt den
primären Rohstoffverbrauch zu senken und
geschlossene Stoffkreisläufe zu schaffen
in einer nationalen
kreislaufwirtschaftsstrategie werden wir
gemeinsam mit allen Akteuren die
bestehenden rohstoffpolitischen
Strategien bündeln auch die Flut von
einwegplastik die noch viel zu oft in
der Umwelt landet soll so bewältigt
werden
das führt mich zum transformationsfeld
schadstofffreie Umwelt saubere Luft
gesunde Gewässer und intakte Böden sind
überlebenswichtig für Mensch und Natur
deshalb unterstützt die Bundesregierung
das von der EU-Kommission ausgerufene
Null verschmutzungsziel und er greift
auf nationaler Ebene Maßnahmen für eine
giftfreie Umwelt deshalb
bereiten wir einen Aktionsplan vor gegen
hormonell schädliche Stoffe deshalb
suchen wir nach Lösungen um den Einsatz
schädlicher und langlebiger Chemikalien
wie pe-phas zu reduzieren deshalb
stimmen wir eine nationale
wasserstrategie ab die unter anderem
dazu beitragen soll dass unsere
seenflüsse und Meere wieder gesünder
werden deshalb haben wir erstmals einen
meeresschutzbeauftragten der
Bundesregierung benannt er wird auch die
internationalen Bemühungen um ein
Abkommen gegen die Vermüllung der Meere
vorantreiben
unser Handeln muss auch und gerade in
Krisenzeiten dazu beitragen dass wir
unsere natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
besser schützen das verlangt das Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts aber auch
die schlichte Verantwortung gegenüber
unseren Kindern und Enkeln
wir müssen und werden die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik der
Bundesregierung insgesamt modernisieren
wir wollen die Verbindlichkeit von
Nachhaltigkeitszielen erhöhen sei es im
Klima und Biodiversitätsschutz bei den
Bürgerrechten und in der nationalen in
der deutschen Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
selber wir werden außerdem Fortschritte
beim sdt-gipfel 2030 voranbringen nur
mit einer ambitionierten Umsetzung der
Agenda 2030 werden die Lebens- und
entwicklungsschancen dieser und
künftiger Generationen besser als bisher
gewahrt um die Krisen unserer Zeit
bewältigt es kann gelingen das globale
Engagement besonders junger Menschen für
eine lebenswerte Zukunft stimmt mich
sehr zuversichtlich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nachhaltigkeit heißt die aktuellen
Krisen anzugehen und dabei die
langfristigen nicht aus den Augen zu
verlieren die Woche der Nachhaltigkeit
ruft das in Erinnerung daran will ich
mit ihnen arbeiten nicht nur diese
sondern alle kommen Wochen vielen Dank
Bettina Hoffmann Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin bei der
Bundesumweltministerin die hier anwesend
ist und ich hatte jetzt zuletzt auch den
Eindruck dass Frau Hoffmann diese Rede
stellvertretend gehalten hat wir klären
das mal zwischenzeitlich Rainer Kraft
ist am Pult für und aus der afd-fraktion
ob man im parlamentarischen Beirat für
nachhaltige Entwicklung
wir debattieren heute über die sechs
Prinzipien der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie behauptet in
mit der Neufassung der Prinzipien eine
bessere Übereinstimmung mit der Agenda
2030 der Vereinten Nationen gebracht zu
haben aber ist das wirklich der Fall die
Prinzipien fordern unter anderem den
Erhalt der natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
weiterhin den Schutz der Umwelt und die
Nutzung erneuerbarer Naturgüter nur im
Rahmen ihrer Regenerationsfähigkeit
soweit so gut allerdings stellt sich
dann natürlich die Frage wie sie bei zum
Beispiel wäre Energiepolitik begründen
bei der sie die Absicht von tausende
Hektar an Fläche in industrielle
brachlandschaften zu verwandeln sind
Wälder denn keine natürliche
Lebensgrundlage doch das sind sie sind
Wiesen und Weiden etwa keine Umwelt doch
ja das sind sie auch und wie sieht
eigentlich die natürliche
Regenerationsfähigkeit eines
verdichteten ex-waldstückes aus auf dem
nun eine 160 Meter hohentausende Tonnen
schwere stahlbetonsäule prank genannt
Windrad ja da ist dann keinerlei
regenerationsfähigkeiten mehr gegeben
ergo widerspricht ihr totaler und
radikaler Ausbau der fälschlicher
erneuerbar bezeichneten Energien den
Nachhaltigkeitsprinzip Nummer 3
des weiteren fordertprinzip 3 mit nicht
nachwachsenden Naturgütern so sparsam
wie möglich umzugehen warum aber setzt
dann die Bundesregierung auf diejenigen
energieerzeugungsmethoden die bei
größtmöglichen Materialeinsatz die
geringsten energetischen Ausbeuten
erzielen wie Windindustrie und
PV-Anlagen
beides widersprechen natürlich dem
nachhaltigkeitsziel Nummer 7 der Agenda
2030 der Vereinten Nationen für eine
bezahlbare zuverlässige nachhaltige und
moderne Energieversorgung
neu ist das nicht ich habe in das von
dieser Stelle aus vielfach schon gesagt
die aber von ihnen der Regierung und ja
leider auch in den beiden anderen
Oppositionsparteien favorisierte
Energiepolitik mittels Wetter Tages- und
jahreszeitenabhängige Energien führt
eben zu einer teuren und zur
verlässlichen archaischen und damit eben
nicht nachhaltigen Energieversorgung
das führt dann natürlich auch dazu dass
ihre Energiepolitik auch den Prinzip mit
4 und 5 widerspricht das mit dieser
teuren Energie kein nachhaltiges
Wirtschaften mehr möglich ist bzw diese
Verteuerung den sozialen Zusammenhalt
gefährdet statt ihn zu verbessern
ja und die ersten
steht wärmehallen vor zahllose Familien
verarmen oder frieren bereits und sie
nennen diese Politik ernsthaft
nachhaltig wirklich
ja kommen wir noch einmal zur Einhaltung
der planetaren Grenzen
ja die werden im Winter wieder
funktionieren helenker keine Sorge es
ist eine der erfolgreichsten Lügen das
Rohstoffe durch die Nutzung verbraucht
werden das ist nicht der Fall diese Güte
werden gebraucht und sind auch nach
Beendigung des Gebrauchs als Materie
grundsätzlich vorhanden und die uns
bekannte Chemie und Physik ist technisch
ziemlich problemlos in der Lage alles
was nicht mehr benötigt wird wie der
nutzbare Stoffe zu wandeln und die
deutsche Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
fordert in ihrem Prinzip 3 das explizit
nur dafür benötigt man sehr sehr große
Mengen an sehr preiswerte Energie und
hier schließt sich der Kreis durch die
falsche Energiepolitik die auf
Einsparungen setzt auf
energieerzeugungsmethoden die nur
sporadisch und dann auch nur sehr
begrenzt Energie liefern und dafür ein
Vielfaches an Flächen und
Materialaufwand benötigen sind die für
die Nachhaltigkeit nötigen Mengen ein
Energie weder erzeugbar noch bezahlbar
und damit verhindern Sie das Schließen
der stoffkreisläufer damit finden Sie
das Stoffe Materialien wieder auf der
Rohstoffseite eingesetzt werden können
weil sie die Wiedergewinnung der Stoffe
Materialien verteuern aber damit fördern
Sie unsere Abhängigkeit von
autokratischen Regimen wie Tina
Saudi-Arabien Katar Aserbaidschan oder
auch Russland und anstatt in der
Energiepolitik Verzicht und Not als das
Leitmotiv zu wählen wäre es angebracht
den Aufbruch in ein Energiezeitalter zu
beginnen Mengen und Mengen ein sehr
preiswerter Energie um all die guten
Vorsätze der Agenda 2030 in die Realität
umzusetzen
eine Begründung der Wüsten und eine
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung in den
schwächste Regionen dieser Welt das wäre
möglich und ja nur wenn es Deutschland
wirtschaftlich gut geht können wir
überhaupt auch nur andere Nationen noch
beistehen was sie so gern tun aber es
geht Deutschland nicht mehr gut
sie befinden sich also mit der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie im Konflikt mit
sich selbst und mit der Agenda 2030 und
das alles nur um der Durchsetzung ihrer
ideologischen klassenkampfziele zu
genügen die Versorgungssicherheit grüner
ideologieberufe und grüner
Vorfeldorganisationen steht bei über der
Versorgungssicherheit der Nation
der Gedanke der Nachhaltigkeit ist bis
zur Unkenntlichkeit pervertiert die
Alternative für Deutschland versteht den
Begriff der Nachhaltigkeit in seinem
ureigenen konservativen bewahrungs
genannten ressourcenschonend effizient
und dem Wohl eines selbstbestimmten
eigenverantwortlichen Individuums
verpflichtet wir wehren und sowohl gegen
ihre planwirtschaftliche Transformation
als auch ihre staatliche Umerziehung
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Christoph Meyer Christoph Meyer ist
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der FDP-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren in einer Zeit in der
die Politik auf Bundes auf Landesebene
auf europäischer Ebene seit Monaten über
milliardenschwere entlastungspakete
ringt in einer Woche in der wir sehen
dass in Großbritannien die Grenzen der
eigenen schuldenaufnahmefähigkeit
getestet werden an einem Tag an dem der
Haushaltsausschuss über den Haushalt
2023 diskutiert und auch das gehört dazu
der ein oder andere
Bundestagsabgeordnete immer noch darüber
schwadroniert dass der Staat ja bei der
Bundesbank Kredite aufnehmen können und
man
kreditrückzahlungskonditionen politisch
festlegen könne sind wir als FDP der
Auffassung dass wir in ein
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte zunächst erstmal
über fiskalische Resilienz und
finanzpolitische Stabilität diskutieren
müssen
wir werden in der Debatte jetzt
sicherlich noch einiges über die
Grundprinzipien von Nachhaltigkeit hören
und es ist glaube ich klar dass
Disziplin und Priorisierung dazugehört
priorisiere und nutze nur so viel wie du
tatsächlich brauchst handle mit
langfristiger Perspektive und
hinterlasse deinen Kindern keine
schweren Hypotheken deshalb haben wir
als FDP in diesen Koalitionsvertrag die
Schuldenbremse reinverhandelt und dazu
stehen wir auch nach wie vor
da kann da kann die Union klatschen und
es wäre schön wenn die CDU ihren
Kollegen aus Bayern denn auch klar macht
dass auch sie dafür sind der ein oder
andere aus Bayern scheint das ja nicht
ganz richtig verstanden zu haben
wir erleben auch das in der Debatte
glaube ich noch ein bisschen zu kurz
gekommen eine ökonomische Zeitenwende
die Zeit ist nullzinses ist vorbei und
wenn wir über Schuldentragfähigkeit
sprechen uns vergegenwärtigen dass wir
im Jahr 2023 30 Milliarden Euro
Zinskosten tragen müssen dann ist das
ein Volumen im Vergleich zu 2021 wo der
gesamte Etat des Umweltministeriums des
Außenministeriums des Ministeriums für
Familie reingehen würde und das macht
die Dimension deutlich weswegen ist
wichtig ist dass wir als Koalition wir
als FDP vorneweg das Finanzministerium
die Schuldenbremse auch im Jahr 2023
verteidigen werden und zwar nicht damit
irgendwelche allgemeinen politischen
Vorhaben finanziert werden können
sondern dass wir das nötige machen in
der Krise auf der einen Seite auf der
anderen Seite aber solide Haushalten und
die Zukunftsfähigkeit dieses Landes
sichern
und die Schuldenbremse ist daher auch
ein nachhaltigkeitsförderer die
Schuldenbremse wird in den nächsten
Jahren die Politik zwingen
sich zu priorisieren in allen
Einzelplänen in allen Bereichen werden
wir den Gürtel ein Stück weit enger
schnallen müssen weil wir nur so die
Regeln einhalten werden und das wird
nach zehn Jahren ungezügelten Wachstum
was
etat-ansätze angeht was
stellenansätze angeht auch sehr sinnvoll
sein wir werden deswegen
Planungsprozesse beschleunigen zum
Beispiel lng-terminals wir finden es
eigentlich eine sehr gute Entwicklung
dass jetzt lng-terminals schnell gebaut
werden was in den letzten Jahren
versäumt wurden wir werden Bürokratie
abbauen und digitalisieren und wir
werden
wirkungsorientierte Haushaltspolitik
einführen damit das Geld effizienter
eingesetzt werden kann auch das gehört
zur Wahrheit dazu dass der Staat alleine
all die ganzen Ziele die hier auch
bisher genannt wird nicht schaffen
werden können mit eigenen Leistungen
sondern wir brauchen private
Investitionen private Problemlöser und
auch dafür steht die FDP dass das in den
nächsten Jahren zu kurz kommt wir sind
wir sind bei aller Kritik was die
ökologische Nachhaltigkeit was den
Klimaschutz angeht in Deutschland schon
weltweit führend was die finanzielle
Nachhaltigkeit angeht haben wir noch ein
wenig Aufholbedarf und wir werden dafür
sorgen dass die Ampel auch das nicht aus
dem Blick verliert ich danke Ihnen
Christoph Meyer FDP-Fraktion dort einer
der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden in
der vereinbarten Debatte des Deutschen
Bundestags zur deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie ein weites Feld
ein zukunftsorientiertes Feld und da
spricht jetzt Bernd Riexinger aus der
Linksfraktion wo er Sprecher für
nachhaltige Mobilität ist
die Zukunft Menschheit hängt nach einer
aktuellen Studie des Club of Rom von
fünf kehrwänden ab Beendigung der Armut
Beseitigung der eklatanten Ungleichheit
Ermächtigung der Frauen
Aufbau eines für Menschen und Ökosysteme
gesunden nahrungsmittelsystems Übergang
zum Einsatz sauberer Energie das ist
Nachhaltigkeit im umfassenden Sinne
damit umschreibt der Klappe from
prägnant dass wir uns in einer
geschichtlichen Phase
multipler-krisen des Kapitalismus
befinden die sich gegenseitig
verschränken und verschärfen und ohne
eine radikale Änderung der Wirtschafts-
wir wissen dass wir nur noch 15 Jahre
Zeit haben um die Weichen radikal
umzustellen für den Körper from ist
Gleichheit und Gerechtigkeit der
Königsweg für eine lebenswerte Zukunft
also ungefähr das pure Gegenteil von dem
was die ampelregierung Macht und die
größte Oppositionspartei gemacht hat von
einer Beendigung der weltweiten armut
kann keine Rede sein aber die bisherige
Politik schafft es nicht einmal in einem
der reichsten Länder der Welt Armut und
Kinderarmut erfolgreich zu bekämpfen
die Ungleichheit ist während der
Pandemie noch größer geworden sie
schaffen es nicht einmal eine
lächerliche übergewinnsteuer auf den Weg
zu bringen oder in irgendeiner Form
reiche und Vermögende an den Kosten der
Krisen zu beteiligen von der Forderung
des Körpers Rom dass die reichsten zehn
Prozent die Investitionen für
Klimaschutz aufbringen müssen sind sie
weiter entfernt als die Erde vom Mond
statt die Menschen zu entlasten die es
dringend benötigen machen Sie ein
inflationsausgleichsgesetz bei dem die
am meisten entlastet werden die ohnehin
die höchsten Einkommen haben wir sind
eines der wirtschaftlich stärksten
Länder
bei denen die Frauen immer noch
durchschnittlich 20% weniger verdienen
als die Männer wann wird endlich der
Grundsatz eingelöst gleicher
lohnvergleichwertige Arbeit
und beim Übergang zum Einsatz sauberer
Energien hat Deutschland längst seine
Vorreiterrolle verloren statt der
Forderung von frei.day for future
nachzugehen nämlich einen Klimaschutz
vor von 100 Milliarden einzurichten
rüsten Sie lieber die Bundeswehr um 100
Milliarden auf sie schaffen es nicht
einmal bei der Energieknappheit ein
Tempolimit zu verabschieden von einer
nachhaltigen mobilitätswende die diesen
Namen verdient ganz zu schweigen für
einen sozialökologischen Systemwechsel
müssen Gerechtigkeit und
Klimagerechtigkeit
zusammengedacht werden dazu sind wir
bereit danke schön
Bernd rexinger aus der Linksfraktion das
ist ja die Fraktion die die meisten
aktuellen und ehemaligen
Parteivorsitzenden in ihren Reihen hat
auch Bernd rixinger Weiher mal
Vorsitzender der Linken einige Jahre
sogar ihm folgt jetzt am Pult Sarah
rücklewski Staatsministerin für Bund
länderbeziehungen beim Bundeskanzler und
ich sie ist auch zuständig für die
Koordination von Nachhaltigkeitszielen
in den einzelnen Ressorts der
Bundesregierung hat nachhaltige
Entwicklung als men to the moon Projekt
beschrieben
der mundflug unserer Generation so
Professor Sachs und ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidentin ist die
nachhaltige Entwicklung auf der Erde um
Erfolg zu haben bedarf es einer nicht
weniger mutigen Kraftanstrengung als
beim Mondflug
aus dem Weltall wirkt unsere Erde wie
ein großes Raumschiff so hat es der
deutsche isar-astronaut Matthias Maurer
in diesem Jahr bei seiner Rede beim
Weltwirtschaftsgipfel in Davos
beschrieben er war dabei von der
internationalen Raumstation zugeschaltet
das ändert die Perspektive und er hat
hinzugefügt die Crew die Menschheit
sollte zusammenarbeiten um die
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit zu
bewältigen
und dieses gemeinsame anpacken ist heute
wichtiger denn je gerade auch vor dem
Hintergrund des brutalen angriffskriegs
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und
natürlich hat dieser Krieg es wäre
illusorisch zu denken dass es anders
wäre Auswirkungen auf die Frage wie wir
unsere sdg-ziele erreichen können aber
er macht auch noch mal sehr deutlich
dass eigentlich kein Weg an ihnen
vorbeiführt wir merken gerade dass die
Abhängigkeit von fossiler Energie in
zweierlei Hinsicht und nachhaltig auch
beeinflusst wir sind zum einen von der
Endlichkeit abhängig zum anderen machen
wir uns auch bei der Kompensation immer
wieder von Staaten im Zweifelsfall
abhängig die unsere Werte nicht teilen
und die SDG geben wir uns auch in der
Langfristperspektive eine Möglichkeit
aus diesem Dilemma rauszubekommen denn
mit den 17 Sustainable Development Goals
der Agenda 2030 haben sich alle Staaten
zur gemeinsamen Verantwortung bekannt
für gute Lebensperspektiven heutiger und
künftiger Generationen
zusammenzuarbeiten internationale
Zusammenarbeit ist der Schlüssel zur
Lösung unserer globalen Probleme
und schon seit 2002 hat Deutschland eine
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie sie ist der
Rahmen für die deutsche Umsetzung der
Agenda 2030 und wurde zuletzt 2021
überarbeitet die Strategie enthält 75
konkrete Ziele sowie die Ex
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien über die wir
heute sprechen die Ziele aber auch die
Prinzipien zeigen nachhaltigkeit ist für
alle Politikbereiche von großer
Bedeutung das erste
Nachhaltigkeitsprinzip fordert
nachhaltige Entwicklung als Leitprinzip
in allen Bereichen und bei allen
Entscheidungen anzuwenden und
Bundesministerin Svenja Schulze und die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
Hoffmann haben das ja auch sehr
eindrücklich für ihre Politikbereiche
auch dargestellt
aber wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen wir
müssen richtig richtig auf die Tube
drücken bei dem Thema wir haben nur noch
sehr sehr wenig Zeit um die sdgs zu
erreichen und wir müssen hier eine
Schippe drauflegen und da hat sich die
Bundesregierung und Koalitionsvertrag
ein ambitioniertes Ziel gesetzt wir
wollen die 17 sdgs als Richtschnur
unserer Politik umsetzen und hierfür
werden wir die Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
konsequent weiterentwickeln
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Bundeskabinett hat mich am 24 August mit
der Zuständigkeit für nachhaltige
Entwicklung betraut zusammen mit allen
Bundesministerien arbeiten wir daran im
staatssekretärsausschuss für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und wir wollen das
tatsächlich Nachhaltigkeit zur
Richtschnur der Politik der
Bundesregierung wird dafür ist aus
meiner Sicht zweierlei wichtig alle
Ministerien müssen im Ausschuss aktiv
mitwirken und Sie müssen das als ein
Instrument nutzen um ihre Politik an
Nachhaltigkeit auszurichten
das ist bis jetzt der Fall wer hat deine
erste sehr sehr gute Sitzung wo auch
alle wirklich sehr committed waren
Helmut Kleber liegt gerade er war auch
mit dabei weil auch das gehört dazu wir
möchten den Austausch haben nicht nur in
diesem Ausschuss Regierung und
Parlament Regierung nicht nur den
Austausch innerhalb der Regierung
sondern wir wollen aktiv auf Sie als
Parlament zu gehen deswegen gerne auch
die Einladung an die
CDU-Bundestagsfraktion ich komme auch
gerne zu Ihnen und wir diskutieren über
das Thema weil wir eben aus der Blase
raus müssen und wir wollen diesen
Ausschuss auch als Strategie Forum
nehmen denn Nachhaltigkeit das hat die
Debatte hier gezeigt dass ein gutes
Thema ist ein wichtiges Thema ich finde
auch es ist ein schönes Thema aber es
darf kein wohlfühlthema werden auch das
hat die Debatte gezeigt wir erleben doch
am Ende wenn es konkret geht wenn es um
die Frage geht wie wir Politik auch
genau ausrichten dann haben wir
natürlich Differenzen aber diese
Differenzen die müssen wir ausreichen
die müssen wir ausdiskutieren nur so
schaffen wir wirklich Fortschritte im
Bereich der Nachhalt Möglichkeit
ich möchte insbesondere die sechs
transformationsbereiche hervorheben die
wir zum Schwerpunkt der Arbeit im
Ausschuss in den kommenden Monaten
machen werden natürlich gehören dazu die
Bereiche Klima und Energie das hat ja
auch hier die Debatte geprägt es gilt
aber auch für das Thema
kreisverwirtschaft eine schadstofffreie
Umwelt nachhaltige agrar- und
ernährungssysteme bauen und Verkehr und
natürlich immer wieder wenn es um das
Wohl der Menschen geht die soziale
Gerechtigkeit und nach meiner
Überzeugung ist die Transformation
Deutschlands zu einer nachhaltigen
Gesellschaft die beste Antwort auf die
weltweite Klima Energie und
rohstoffkrise die wir derzeit erleben
und damit ist sie wichtiger denn je
aber
Transformation wir reden immer so viel
darüber die muss auch irgendwo konkret
stattfinden und deswegen müssen wir an
einem Strang ziehen deshalb freue ich
mich sehr dass ich am Montag in
Vertretung für den erkrankten
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz gemeinsam mit
dem Ministerpräsidenten von
Nordrhein-Westfalen hinweg wüst das vom
Nachhaltigkeitsrat koordinierte
Gemeinschaftswerk nachhaltigkeitsstaaten
durfte das Gemeinschaftswerk der
bundesweit eine Plattform sein für alle
Aktivitäten im Bereich der
Nachhaltigkeit von den lokalen
Nachhaltigkeitsinitiativen über
Sportvereine den Mittelstand Kommunen
bis hin zu Dax-Konzernen die sich für
einen nachhaltige Gesellschaft einsetzen
auch hier geht es wieder darum wir
müssen konkret werden wir müssen das in
der Politik sicherstellen dass wir die
Rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen dass
Nachhaltigkeit auch gelebt werden kann
dass sie umgesetzt werden kann aber wir
müssen auch eine Plattform dafür
schaffen damit es am Ende konkret
stattfinden kann
Nachhaltigkeit ich habe das vorhin
gesagt es ist ein gutes Thema und das
zeigt auch dass dieses Thema von vielen
Akteuren mitgetragen wird das sehen wir
gerade jetzt in der europäischen
nachhaltigkeitswoche in diesem Jahr gab
es wieder mehr als 6.000 Aktivitäten in
25 europäischen Ländern allein in
Deutschland
3.800 und ich möchte ganz deutlich sagen
ganz herzlichen Dank an alle die
mitgemacht haben
und meine herzliches Dankeschön gilt an
dieser Stelle auch an den
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachher
Kritiker Entwicklung für seine wichtige
Arbeit in den vergangenen Jahren aber
nach allem was ich gehört habe möchten
Sie sich ja auch noch mal neu aufstellen
auch in der Frage wie wir dann auch bei
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben genau darauf
schauen ob das Prinzip Nachhaltigkeit
umgesetzt wird ich freue mich da sehr
auf den Dialog den Diskurs und
vielleicht auch mal auf ein paar
Reibereien wenn wir mal gesagt bekommen
hier ist das noch nicht umgesetzt worden
aber genau darum muss es gehen wir
müssen hier genauer hinschauen wir
müssen auch nachhalten und im
Zweifelsfall dann auch nachbessern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich komme
zum Schluss ich möchte noch einmal
bekräftigen die Bundesregierung wird
sich weiter für eine nachhaltige
Entwicklung einsetzen ganz im Sinne des
Koalitionsvertrags als Bündnis für
Freiheit Gerechtigkeit und
Nachhaltigkeit und deswegen achten wir
über Parteigrenzen hinweg darauf dass
wir mit unserem wirken nicht nur den
Bedürfnissen der heutigen gen schon
gerecht werden sondern wir immer auch
die Bedürfnisse der künftigen
Generationen im Blick haben und einen
Satz möchte ich aber dann doch einem
noch mal sagen weil wer darüber
gesprochen haben dass es vielleicht auch
mal Differenzen gibt ich glaube es gibt
Schulden die man vererben kann es gibt
aber auch Hypotheken die man vererben
kann weil man an anderer Stelle nichts
getan hat und zu wenig investiert hat
vielen Dank
Sarah rücklewski Staatsministerin beim
Bundeskanzler so ist ja der offizielle
Titel koordiniert das Thema
Nachhaltigkeit zwischen den
verschiedenen Ressorts in einer
stadtsekretärsrunde und hat vorhin
gesagt dass dort alle sehr committed
waren also sich dem Thema verpflichtet
fühlen so kann man es mal übersetzen
Ralf Brinkhaus aus der Unionsfraktion
ist ebenfalls Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Beirat der hier schon
so häufig angesprochen wurde das was ich
in den letzten Jahren erlebt habe mal
als folgendes und zwar als seriellen
Alarmismus was bedeutet serieller
Alarmismus wir haben immer ein Thema da
ist Vollalarm das ist voll von den
Debatten hier in den Talkshows an den
medialen Lagerfeuern in den Zeitungen
und alle anderen Themen fallen heben wo
hinten runter es ist so dass mich
gestern in einer Schülergruppe eine
Schülerin gefragt habe redet ihr
eigentlich noch über kovic wir machen
uns da irgendwie Sorgen was da im Winter
passiert oder habt ihr nur noch ein
Thema meine Damen und Herren das ist
verständlich dass wir momentan dieses
große Thema Russland und die Folgen und
Energiekrise haben das ist auch sehr
sehr menschlich aber wenn sie mal die
letzten Jahrzehnte so zurückblicken gab
es nicht immer irgendwie ein großes
Thema was viel viel wichtiger war seit
angefangen irgendwann mal mit der
Finanz- und Bankenkrise die war dann
ganz wichtig dann die Eurokrise Teil 1
dann ist Fukushima hochgegangen dann war
die Euro-Krise Teil 2 dann haben wir nur
über Migration geredet dann hatten wir
noch den Trump dann hatten wir noch den
brexit und dann hatten wir zum Schluss
kobit immer ein großes Thema alle
anderen Sachen sind dabei irgendwie
hinten rübergefallen jetzt will ich
nicht sagen ist da gar nichts gemacht
worden ist aber nicht mit der genügenden
Aufmerksamkeit ich habe das gesehen als
ich mich 2018 gefragt habe als wir
irgendwie sehenden Auges in eine
Situation hineingerannt sind dass wir
unsere Klimaziele nicht erreichen wie
konnte das eigentlich passieren denn
eigentlich gab es auch damals schon
Strategien eigentlich ist auch damals
schon was gemacht worden eigentlich hat
man auch damals schon Sachen umgesetzt
und trotzdem war immer irgendetwas
Wichtigeres zu tun und immer war
irgendein Thema entscheidender als das
Thema Klima Umwelt und Nachhaltigkeit
und wir brauchen das gar nicht auf
umweltbe wir rennen momentan gegen eine
Wand bei den Sozialversicherungssystem
und ganz ehrlich wir wissen doch alle
dass die Abhängigkeit die wir von
Russland haben Kindergeburtstag ist
gegenüber der Abhängigkeit von China das
heißt meine Damen und Herren nachhaltige
langfristige Themen die Fallen irgendwie
immer hinten rüber warum ist das so wir
haben wir haben jetzt einen Debatte zum
Thema Nachhaltigkeit ein großes Dach für
viele Themen meine Vorrednerinnen und
Redner haben das auch beleuchtet und das
wird auch heute noch beleuchtet werden
ist eben nicht nur Klimapolitik nicht
nur Umweltpolitik sondern es geht um
Armut es geht um Hunger es geht um
Gesundheit es geht um Gleichstellung und
viele viele andere Sachen aber jetzt
fragen wir uns noch mal wo fließt das
denn in unserem politischen Alltag ein
da gibt es erstmal eine gute Nachricht
die gute Nachricht ist die Vereinten
Nationen haben sich auf 17 Ziele zur
Nachhaltigkeit geeinigt
und wenn man weiß wie schwierig es ist
auf dieser Ebene ein Konsens zu finden
ist das erstmal wunderbar dass das
überhaupt möglich ist es gibt eine
zweite gute Nachricht diese Ziele sind
sogar untersetzt worden mit Indikatoren
mit Kennzahlen das heißt Politik ist
nicht nur im Ungefähren man müsste mal
man könnte mal und es muss besser werden
nein es gibt konkrete Indikatoren wie
man sowas messen kann beispielsweise
Herr Ritzinger beim Thema Armut die
Menschen die weniger als 1,25 Dollar zur
Verfügung haben es gibt Zahlen zu Frauen
in Führungspositionen es gibt Zahlen zu
Übergewicht zu Rauchern und natürlich
auch die Klimaziele die Zahlen gibt es
und die dritte gute Nachricht meine
Damen und Herren ist diese Zahlen werden
sogar gemessen jedes Jahr hier in
Deutschland beispielsweise vom
Statistischen Bundesamt eure stadtmiss
die Zahlen die Vereinten Nationen geben
jedes Jahr einen Bericht heraus wie die
ganze Sache sich weiterentwickelt
aber hat das ein Einfluss auf unsere
politische Tätigkeit hier ist es so dass
wir morgens aufstehen und sagen hey
welches nachhaltigkeitsziel nehmen wir
uns heute mal vor wo arbeiten wir heute
dran was machen wir dagegen das wird in
einem Ampelsystem gemacht dass die
Ampeln bei der ein oder anderen Kennzahl
auf Rot oder auf gelb ist nein unser
politisches Tagesgeschehen wird auch
davon geprägt dass wir versuchen den Tag
zu gewinnen dass wir versuchen abends
unfallfrei ins Bett zu kommen und dass
man vielleicht nebenher noch mal das ein
oder andere erledigen kann und ich sage
das ist jetzt kein Thema meine Damen und
Herren zwischen Opposition und Regierung
das geht uns allen an das ist übrigens
auch kein Thema zwischen Politik und
Medien das geht uns alle an und da
müssen wir uns alle in die Augen schauen
was da passiert ja und Frau reglewski
natürlich haben wir ein
staatssekretärsausschuss stellt sich nur
die Frage wieso ist es eigentlich nicht
ein hochkarätiger ministerausschuss wenn
es so wichtig ist wieso ist dieser
Staatssekretär als Ausschuss erst nach
neun Monaten in Gang gesetzt worden und
früher ja wir haben einen Rat für
Nachhaltige Entwicklung da wird tolle
Arbeit gemacht da war die Tagung am
Montag ja wir haben auch ein
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sitzen hier und die sind alle
ganz ganz ganz engagiert aber hat das
was da besprochen wird Auswirkung auf
das was wir hier in Gesetze reingießen
ich sage ganz ehrlich viel zu wenig und
jetzt
es könnte ich
sagen
Opposition jammern ist genug ich werfe
ein paar Steine und es ist alles
schlecht Nein
das reicht nicht weil eins ist auch
richtig wir sind hier der Deutsche
Bundestag wir sind das Parlament wir
haben es in der Hand das zu ändern wir
können dem Thema eine Bühne geben das
machen wir heute mit drei Stunden hätte
mir ein bisschen mehr Leidenschaft in
der Debatte gewünscht an der ein oder
anderen Stelle das machen wir heute in
drei Stunden aber da sitzt der Kollege
Mirsch wir haben es vereinbart wir
wollten eigentlich eine Woche raus
machen wir hätten hier die Gelegenheit
gehabt in einer Woche genauso wie wir es
bei den Haushaltsberatungen machen jedes
nachhaltigkeitsziel zu besprechen jeden
Minister zu hören die
oppositionsvorschläge zu hören wir
hätten die Gelegenheit gehab wirklich
das in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen was
viele leider viel zu wenig wissen diese
Gelegenheit die haben wir verpasst das
ist jetzt vergossene Milch das wird
nichts mehr ich werbe wirklich dafür
dass die Mehrheit es anders macht und
dass die Mehrheit es beim nächsten Mal
mit uns beschließt dass wir wirklich
eine nachhaltigkeitswoche machen und
Einsatz gestatten Sie mir noch frau
Präsidentin reden reicht nicht weil
geredet wird genug dass es mal besser
werden müsste ich werbe sogar noch für
eine weitere Sache und das vielleicht so
ein bisschen als gedankenfutter für die
weitere Debatte ich werde dafür dass wir
genauso wie wir einen Haushaltsplan
aufstellen wo wir alle
haushaltskennzahlen in einem Buch
hineinschreiben und darüber sprechen
dass wir alle nachhaltigkeitskennzahlen
in einem nachhaltigkeitsplan beraten
dass wir uns genauso zwei Wochen wie für
die Haushaltsberatung Zeit nehmen und
dass wir dann die Regierung daran messen
ob diese Zahlen ob diese Ziele jährlich
erfüllt worden sind oder nicht das wäre
nachhaltig und damit würden wir
Nachhaltigkeit in den Deutschen
Bundestag bringen herzlichen Dank
Ralf Brinkhaus aus dem parlamentarischen
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung mit
einem sehr grundsätzlichen mit einem
sehr nachdenklichen Beitrag in dieser
Debatte über den politischen Alltag und
über die und zu der Frage dass der
Politik häufig nur in Tagesaktualität
gedacht und wird auch Berichterstattung
nur auf tagesaktuelle Entwicklung
ausgerichtet wird aber langfristig nur
langfristig lösbare Aufgaben dann häufig
hinten runterfallen und auch die
Debatten dazu
am Pult bzw auf dem Weg dorthin jetzt
Tessa gansera ob Frau im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und heute morgen schon bei
uns im Interview
mich sehr dass wir heute hier an einem
prominenten Zeit Platz zum Thema
Nachhaltigkeit
debattieren und meine Vorbereitung
meiner Rede habe ich mir Gedanken
gemacht wie die Debatte wohl verlaufen
wird und ich habe mich ganz bewusst
entschieden nicht in ein
parteipolitisches Kleinklein zu
verfallen weil mir weil dieses Thema in
der nachhaltigen Entwicklung einfach
viel zu wichtig ist und wie die
bundesministerins Svenja Schulze und
auch die Staatssekretärin Bettina
Hoffmann schon deutlich gemacht haben es
geht hier um nichts Geringeres als dafür
zu sorgen dass alle Menschen hier in
Deutschland aber auf dem kompletten
kommt auf der kompletten Planeten ein
gutes Leben in Würde führen können und
dass wir das auch unseren Enkelkindern
und urenkelkindern ermöglichen müssen
und dafür
dafür ist es notwendig dass wir alle
unsere Lebens- und Wirtschaftsweise so
gestalten dass dabei die ökologischen
Belastungsgrenzen unseres Planeten nicht
überschritten werden und ich möchte an
dieser Stelle positiv herausheben dass
wir hier eine eigentlich einen breiten
parteipolitischen Konsens haben seit
2002 gibt es in Deutschland eine
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie an der die
jeweilige Bundesregierung und zwar
unabhängig von ihrem parteipolitischen
Farbzusammensetzung festgehalten hat und
diese
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie jeweils auch
fortgeschritten hat
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir ehrlich
feststellen dass mir vom Erreichen der
Nachhaltigkeitsziele national wie Global
noch meilenweit davon entfernt sind und
zur aktuelle Krisen wie die
corona-pandemie oder jetzt dieser
fürchterliche Angriffskrieg stellen uns
natürlich vor unerwarteten
Herausforderungen auf die wir auch
kurzfristig Antworten finden müssen aber
wir dürfen dabei natürlich das
langfristige Ziel dann nachhaltigen
Entwicklung nicht aus den Augen
verlieren und wir müssen deswegen unsere
Kraftanstrengung auch noch intensivieren
damit man diese Ziele nicht nicht
verpassen dass wir die Ziele
informationsteams eingesetzt an den eine
ressortübergreifend an denen der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie festgelegten
transformationsbereichen
ressortübergreifend vernetzt
zusammengearbeitet werden soll und ich
erachte das für ein wahnsinnig wichtigen
Schritt weil nämlich hier bei einer
Umsetzung der Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
alle Ministerien mitarbeiten müssen
darüber hinaus ist es meiner Überzeugung
dringend notwendig dass wir die
Nachhaltigkeit
Überprüfung in der
gesetzesfolgenabschätzung so wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart auch noch
mehr Gewicht verleihen dazu muss von
einer formalen Überprüfung diese
Nachhaltigkeit zu Überprüfung zu einer
qualitativen Prüfung weiterentwickelt
werden und eben auch der Klima-Check mit
eingebunden werden weil beides ergänzt
und bedingt sich miteinander ich würde
sogar dafür werden dass wir bei dieser
nachhaltigkeitsüberprüfung zu mehr
Ehrlichkeit kommen dass wir auch offen
und transparent
gewisse Zielkonflikte ja das ist in der
Vergangenheit bisher nicht passiert dass
wir in der Nachhaltigkeit zu Überprüfung
Zielkonflikte transparent offenlegen und
damit deutlich machen wenn wir uns für
ein Ziel entscheiden was wichtig ist da
kann man gute Gründe finden aber sehen
dass mir einen anderen Bereich
Zielkonflikte haben dann müssten wir
dort unsere Anstrengungen noch weiterhin
intensivieren
und auch im Deutschen Bundestag muss
musste die Nachhaltigkeitspolitik
deutlich gestärkt werden der ppne als
Ort wo frei und wirklich am
zielorientiert diskutiert wird dieser
gute Ort ich lade Sie ein kommen sie zu
Anhörungen für uns aber bei konkreten
Entscheidungen bei den Umsetzungen ist
der PPN eher außen vor und deswegen bin
ich der Überzeugung dass dieser Ort für
die Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte gestärkt
werden muss dass der ppne mehr
Kompetenzen benötigt wir werden hier wie
im einsetzungsantrag beschlossen
entsprechende Vorschläge liefern denn
gebraucht wird der ppne auf jeden Fall
das Thema ist so wichtig es hat die
Vorgänger die vorgehenden reden und es
wird auch die jetzt noch folgende
Debatte zeigen dass dieses Thema wichtig
ist und dass es hier auch im Deutschen
Bundestag eine Entscheidungsgremium
braucht wo wir wirklich an der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie debattieren
können vielen Dank
Tessa gansera aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen und weil Abkürzungen
gelegentlich verwirren können pbne ist
natürlich nichts anderes als der
parlamentarische Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung nächster Redner Enrico
combling afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren Kollegen der
französische Schriftsteller Paul Claudel
hat einmal gesagt bevor man die Welt
verändert wäre es vielleicht doch
wichtiger sie nicht zugrunde zu richten
mit ihrer Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie Liebe
Bundesregierung machen sie genau das sie
richten die Welt oder besser zunächst
Deutschland zugrunde
ihre Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie mit ihren
sogenannten sechs Prinzipien ist nichts
anderes als ein kommunistisches manifest
ebenso ebenso wie dieses im Jahr 1848
die Abschaffung der bürgerlichen
Gesellschaft propagierte soll heute ihre
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die sozial
ökologische Transformation der
Gesellschaft Herbeiführen von
staatswegen befohlen und vom Staat
kontrolliert und wir sehen es ja jetzt
schon diese Transformation führt dazu
dass die Industrie die Arbeit einstellt
das Handwerk und Mittelstand kollabieren
das Bauern immer weniger produzieren
dürfen sie führt dazu dass die Menschen
im Winter frieren müssen und sich das
Brot vom Bäcker nicht mehr leisten
können ihrer Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
mangelt es vor allem an Nachhaltigkeit
Ronald Reagan hat vollkommen recht als
er 1981 feststellte der Staat löst nicht
die Probleme er ist das Problem in ihrem
Papier in ihrem Papier spielt das Wort
Freiheit keinerlei Rolle dabei sind
Nachhaltigkeit und Freiheit zwei Seiten
derselben Medaille Nachhaltigkeit kann
nur in Freiheit erwachsen nur Freiheit
und Selbstverantwortung der Menschen
schaffen sozialen Zusammenhalt die in
ihrem Papier angesprochene offene
Gesellschaft kann aber nur bestehen aus
Individuen die sich freiwillig
zusammenschließen in Familien in
Betrieben und in Vereinen nur die
Freiheit des Marktes schafft tatsächlich
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften das Problem
ihrer sozialistischen
Kreislaufwirtschaft liegt darin dass sie
in einer Abwärtsspirale gefangen sind
ihr ökosozialismus bedeutet dass es
allen gemeinsam schlechter geht nur der
Wettbewerb des freien Unternehmertums
führt zu einem intelligenteren und nicht
zu einem höheren Ressourceneinsatz
und nur Freiheit vom Staat entfesselt
die Kräfte hebt die Bildung und die
Wissenschaft auf ein höheres Niveau und
bringt Innovationskraft und tatsächlich
nachhaltigen breiten Wohlstand hervor
genau das unterscheidet die
Marktwirtschaft von der
Kreislaufwirtschaft der Kommunisten mit
ihren marxistischen
umverteilungsstrategien die im Grunde
nur eines zur Folge haben nämlich Armut
Freiheit Freiheit ist in Wahrheit das
Grundprinzip einer jeden richtig
verstandenen Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
meine Damen und Herren was jetzt in der
Welt passiert
nicht es wird gemacht es ist das
Ergebnis von
sozialistischer Ideologie von woknis und
känzel cultura von ihrem absurden
Verständnis von Nachhaltigkeit die
negativen Folgen für Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft sind offensichtlich sie
erkennen Sie und nehmen Sie dennoch
billigend in Kauf und als Jurist kann
ich Ihnen sagen das ist Vorsatz
die Menschen da draußen in Deutschland
hier auf den Tribünen hier drin muss
eines klar werden wenn diese Regierung
von Nachhaltigkeit spricht dann wird es
ihnen allen schlechter gehen dann geht
es ihnen an den Kragen wir als AFD sind
das genaue Gegenmodell wir stehen für
die Freiheit vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die FDP-Fraktion
Carina Konrad eine der stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden in der
FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir sind in der schwierigen Zeit
substanzielle Krisen sind gerade Thema
an jedem einzelnen Küchentisch in
Deutschland substanzielle Krisen
bedrohen den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und Nachhaltigkeit die ist
heute geht gehören für mich zusammen mit
Ressourceneffizienz mit Klimaschutz und
Nachhaltigkeit Ressourceneffizienz und
Klimaschutz voranzutreiben das geht nur
indem man Innovationen nutzen ich möchte
meine Redezeit heute mal dafür nutzen
ein paar Vorschläge zu machen wie wir
frei Demokraten uns das vorstellen
Nachhaltigkeit auch nach vorne zu
treiben denn diese substanziellen Krisen
die zwingen uns aus der Komfortzone
heraus das spürt doch jeder gerade ganz
eindeutig es geht um Priorisierung es
geht darum jetzt auch die richtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen für Wohlstand
in der Zukunft zu bewahren
und Hunger das wurde heute schon ein
manchersteller Welt das ist so eine
substanzielle Krise die infolge des
Krieges entstanden ist und wieder groß
geworden ist auf der Welt und das ist
ganz schlimm denn wenn Menschen hungern
dann ist mehr gefährdet wie nur das
einzelne Leben des Menschen dann ist
sozialer Zusammenhalt gefährdet da ist
Ökonomie und Ökologie aus dem
Gleichgewicht geraten und dann ist das
das Gegenteil von nachhaltiger
Entwicklung und ich hatte gestern die
ehrefrau misslein voller zu treffen Frau
Professor Nüßlein Vollert ist
Nobelpreisträgerin und sie hat gesagt es
sei eine Illusion zu glauben man könnte
die Welt allein mit ökologischem Landbau
ernähren und dann mögen manche schon
wieder jubeln das war meine Absicht
aber die Antwort daraus ist es nicht
nicht nachhaltig zu wirtschaften die
Antwort darauf ist es Technologien zu
nutzen Biotechnologien zu nutzen und
nutzbar zu machen in Deutschland um
Nachhaltigkeit voranzutreiben und den
Hunger in der Welt zu bekämpfen
zur nachhaltige Ernährung gehört es auch
die konsequente Nutzung von
Digitalisierung voranzutreiben die
Technisierung weiter voranzutreiben in
Deutschland sind wir wer sehr weit wir
haben führende Landtechnikindustrie in
Deutschland die Vorbild sind und auch
Treiber sind weltweit wir haben eine
Ausbildung die Vorbild und Treiber sein
kann weltweit um Ernährung zu sichern
bei uns aber auch in der Welt und das
ist ein ganz wesentlicher Beitrag zur
Nachhaltigkeit
wasserstoff ist der Energieträger der
Zukunft das soll mein zweiter Punkt sein
an der Stelle und ich bin sehr froh dass
das Ministerium für Bildung und
Forschung die wasserstoffforschung auch
konsequent vorantreibt an der Stelle das
ist ein zentraler Baustein für die
Zukunft für unsere Energieversorgung der
Zukunft so sichern aber auch für den
Verkehrssektor über den wir hier so oft
und so leidenschaftlich diskutieren auch
so weiter zu entwickeln dass wir
klimaneutral werden und das e-fuels in
die Fläche gebracht werden safs nutzbar
gemacht werden das ist jetzt eine
zentral Baustein den wir in Zukunft hier
leisten müssen und den wir jetzt schnell
umsetzen müssen und die Regulierung und
die Voraussetzungen dafür zu schaffen
das ist unsere Aufgabe um Nachhaltigkeit
in diesem Land weiter zu entwickeln und
wir sehen uns auch einig noch kurz ein
dritter Punkt an der Stelle das ist
jetzt zu dem Befinden aus der
Komfortzone auch dazu gehört dass wir
planungsbeschleunigung in diesem Land
konsequent vorantreiben und die
lng-beschleunigungsgesetz hat doch
gezeigt was möglich ist das muss möglich
sein für alle Infrastrukturprojekte in
diesem Land wir haben zu lange uns
darauf ausgeruht aus der Substanz heraus
das zu nutzen was da war jetzt gilt es
nach vorne zu schauen und auch die
richtigen Entscheidungen zu treffen um
Nachhaltigkeit umfassend in diesem Land
weiter voranzutreiben
nächster Redner für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Thomas Lutze
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nachhaltigkeit
ist ja ein schöner begriff er ist aber
auch genauso schön beliebig mittlerweile
kann man selbst Autos nachhaltig kaufen
oder man kann den Erwerb von Aktien und
Immobilienfonds nachhaltig gestalten
eigentlich gibt es kaum noch ein Produkt
oder einen die man was man kaufen kann
oder eine Dienstleistung die man
erwerben kann wo nicht das Siegel
nachhaltig drauf ist daher macht es
durchaus Sinn dass wir hier im Deutschen
Bundestag dieses Thema nicht unter
ferner liefen aufrufen sondern zur
besten Sendezeit vielen Dank dafür
gerade im Verkehrssektor sind die
Voraussetzungen die Herausforderungen
gigantisch es ist nach meiner Auffassung
alles andere als nachhaltig wenn wir
heute die 60 Millionen zugelassenen Pkw
mit Verbrennungsmotoren durch Autos mit
Strom aus Batterien einfach nur
austauschen denn der versiegelte
Verkehrsraum die Verkehrsfläche die
versiegelt wird bleibt dieselbe
Verkehrslärm entsteht auch durch
Rollgeräusche der Reifen und wie diese
Batterien hergestellt werden hat oft mit
Nachhaltigkeit wenig zu tun
nachhaltig erwarten Sie mit Ihrem
richtig nachhaltig wäre es also über
eine mobilitätswende zu diskutieren und
zwar ernsthaft Verkehr zu vermeiden der
nicht unbedingt notwendig ist das wäre
nachhaltig nachhaltig wäre es auch
regionale Wirtschaftskreisläufe viel
stärker zu fördern anstatt Rohstoffe und
Waren über den halben Kontinent der
anzupacken
und damit kein Missverständnis aufkommt
ich bin kein Freund dieser
Herausforderung über Verbote und
Verteuerung zu regeln denn das ist in
der Regel unsozial es muss attraktiver
und günstiger sein wenn man Bus oder
Bahn fährt anstatt mit dem Auto das wäre
auch eigentlich
jetzt haben wir ein Verkehrsministerium
der FDP wobei ich den Eindruck habe dass
dort die Gesamtproblematik durchaus
erkannt wurde das konnte man von den
Vorgängern aus der CSU beim Einsatz
nicht ansatzweise sehen doch bei meinem
Thema den Tempolimit sind die Liberalen
leider im vergangenen Jahrhundert stehen
geblieben ich zitiere das
Bundesumweltamt aus dem Jahre 2020 ein
generelles Tempolimit auf
Bundesautobahnen könnte die
Treibhausgas-Emissionen jährlich jener
Ausgestaltung um 1,9 bis 5,4 Millionen
Tonnen verringern das ist ein Ergebnis
der Berechnung des Umweltbundesamtes und
weiterem Zitat ein Tempolimit auf
Autobahn hilft uns die
treibgashaus-emissionen des Verkehrs in
Deutschland zu senken bei Tempo 120 km/h
liegen die Einsparungen bei 2,6
Millionen Tonnen jährlich selbst ein
Tempolimit von 130 km/h reduziert die
Emulsion bereits um 1, Millionen Tonnen
und zwar sofort und praktisch ohne jede
Mehrkosten mittlerweile gibt es eine
Mehrheit in Deutschland die ein
Tempolimit von 130 km/h befürworten
selbst der ADAC hat seinen Widerstand
aufgegeben es müssten nur die App nur
die FDP sagt leider nein es müssten
allerdings lediglich nur ein paar
hundert neue Verkehrsschilder an den
Grenzen aufgestellt werden aber auch das
wäre nachhaltig vielen Dank
Thomas Lutzer ist Sprecher für
Verkehrspolitik in der Linksfraktion und
sie haben schon gemerkt das wird jetzt
etwas konkreter
in dieser Debatte über die nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie es geht auch um
konkrete Maßnahmen die nötig sind
beispielsweise zum CO2 sparen jetzt Nina
Scheer Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie in der SPD-Fraktion
und Kollegen ich möchte noch mal kurz
einsteigen mit einer
mit einer Rückschau auf die letzten
Jahre weil Herr Brinkhaus sie hatten ja
noch mal aufgefordert dass man irgendwie
einen neuen Blick bräuchte und dabei
auch einen für mich doch sehr
erschreckendes Selbstbild gezeichnet wie
wir über den Tag uns mit
Nachhaltigkeitsthemen Verhalten oder
auch nicht Verhalten ihrer Meinung nach
möchte daran erinnern sie haben gesagt
wir sind hier
mit einem Spaziergang unterwegs was die
Abhängigkeit von Russland betrifft und
haben gesagt dass eigentliche Problem
ist China bzw unser Abhängigkeit von
China erinnert an die Legislaturperiode
2009 bis 13 da begann eine massive
marktverdrängung von Seiten Chinas
weltweit angelegt mit 300 Milliarden
Euro wurde damals umgerechnet taxiert
die da zum Ziel hatte nicht wie in
Deutschland und Europa die
Markteinführung wieder erneuerbare
Energien zu fördern sondern die
marktverdrängung aller Akteure zugunsten
Chinas zu vollziehen diese massiv
angelegte marktverdrängung die heute
tatsächlich dazu geführt hat dass wir
auch in Deutschland zu über 90 Prozent
abhängig von China alleine bei der
Photovoltaik sind das war tatsächlich
etwas was auch von der deutschen
Bundesregierung damals unter Angela
Merkel hätte verhindert werden müssen
mit aktiver mit aktiver
Außenhandelspolitik in Europa und für
Deutschland das wurde unterlassen und
das sind die Kardinalfehler Fehler an
denen wir heute jetzt massiv knapsen
weil wir natürlich mit der Erkenntnis
und die ist nicht neu das
Energieversorgung Daseinsvorsorge
eine elementare Frage ist für unser
Wirtschaftssystem für die Gesellschaft
für Sicherheit für Gerechtigkeit für den
sozialen Zusammenhalt wir natürlich
daran arbeiten müssen
Wertschöpfung nach Europa zurückzuholen
Wertschöpfung in Deutschland aufzubauen
aber natürlich auch dafür zu sorgen dass
es international gelingt gleich zu
ziehen im internationalen gemeinsamen
Werk deswegen haben wir ja die sdgs
deswegen haben wir dir auch die sichere
saubere Energie mit der mit Nummer 7 der
sdgs das natürlich gemeinsam zu denken
global zu denken aber immer auch lokal
zu handeln wir dürfen uns nicht
verstecken hinter nur den gemeinsamen
Zielen die brauchen wir als Orientierung
wir brauchen auch immer die
orientierungsfaden wo stehen wir zu
schauen wo sind wir schon angelangt wie
erfolgreich war die zielpolitik aber es
darf wir dürfen uns nicht dahinter
verstecken zu sagen damit ist es getan
natürlich muss Lokal gehandelt werden
und deswegen noch mal kurz
zurückgegriffen auf das was wir auch
gestern im Ausschuss beschlossen haben
und morgen im Bundestag beschließen
werden nämlich zum Beispiel einen
erneuerbaren Energie Booster jetzt noch
mal anzusetzen weil die Energiewende
längst eine Frage der Energie Sicherheit
geworden ist und weil die Sicherheit
nicht gewährleistet werden kann ohne den
beschleunigten Umstieg auf erneuerbare
Energien
und insofern möchte ich auch noch mal
ein paar Blickpunkte darauf werfen wenn
es immer wieder heißt die erneuerbaren
Energien sein der der Kostentreiber das
ist einfach falsch das wird immer wieder
behauptet wir haben Kosten Senkungen bei
Photovoltaik innerhalb der letzten 15
Jahre von 85 Prozent gehabt wir haben
Kostensenkungen bei der Windenergie
innerhalb des gleichen Zeitraums von 55
Prozent gehabt bei der Atomenergie ist
übrigens im gleichen Zeitraum um
ungefähr 30 Prozent gestiegen das wird
immer wieder verleugnet das muss man
immer mal wieder sagen weil nur darüber
kann Bezahlbarkeit von Energie künftig
auch wirklich garantiert werden die
Bezahlbarkeit von Energie und da haben
wir eine Garantenpflicht die hängt daran
dass wir den beschleunigten Umstieg auf
erneuerbare Energien hinbekommen mit dem
energiebooster haben wir einen weiteren
bausteingesetzt den wir hoffentlich
morgen dann auch mit breiter Mehrheit
beschließen werden in diesem Sinne sind
wir auf einem guten Weg vielen Dank
nächster Rednerin für die
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Ingeborg Gräßle
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen ich bin mir in unsicher ob ich
jetzt den Frieden im Hause stören sollte
ich möchte mich bei der Bundesregierung
für die festvorträge bedanken an diesem
Donnerstagmorgen schöne Sonntagsreden
und da wo der Kollege Brinkhaus ja recht
hat wir haben nichts gehört über das
herunterbrechen dieser
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie über
Prioritäten was kommt jetzt was kommt
danach aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
ich den Frieden stören sollte weil es
war so schön ich möchte mich wirklich
bedanken bei der Bundesregierung es war
schön endlich mal wurde die
Vorgängerregierung nicht verantwortlich
gemacht für alles und geht es danke dass
ich das erleben durfte in diesem Haus
macht mich glücklich und trägt mich
durch diesen Tag wirklich danke
ich möchte ich möchte Ihnen schon sagen
dass ich ich möchte eigentlich
einige Dinge hier beisteuern zum
Beispiel
bei der Umsetzung der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie über
Gesetzgebung
und ich möchte darauf verweisen dass
gerade beim Thema Nachhaltigkeit die
Europäische Union ja sehr viel
gesetzgebungs setzt
national noch drauf zu satteln wird
immer wieder gern gemacht aber ich
möchte vorschlagen doch die Verwaltung
mitzunehmen weil wir leiden doch an
einem Umsetzungsproblem von Gesetzgebung
wir leiten nicht in einem Mangel von
Gesetzgebung das heißt laufen sie nicht
schneller als die Verwaltung ihnen
folgen kann weil sonst die ersten Ziele
einfach wertlos sind ich möchte drei
Punkte ansprechen nämlich erstens die
Frage des Haushalts das Haushalt ist
mein Thema und wir sehen natürlich dass
die dass die Staatsfinanzen völlig aus
dem Ruder laufen und dass das
wesentliche Element und Nachhaltigkeit
bei den Staatsfinanzen nämlich die
Schuldenbremse in der Ampel ein ganz
geringes Ansehen hat das haben wir bei
der Rede des Kollegen Meier wieder
gesehen die FDP hat geklatscht immerhin
aber die Ampel wir auch ja also auch die
FDP kann sich auf die Union verlassen in
dem Punkt aber es wäre wichtiger die SPD
um die Grünen an Bord zu haben ich bin
immer wieder bestürzt zu sehen wie wenig
Unterstützung es für dieses nachhaltige
instr gibt und wenn von kaputt sparen
die Rede die Rede ist dann ist das doch
eine Ausrede wir haben ja über 330
Milliarden Steuereinnahmen es ist ja
nicht so dass kein Geld da wäre die
Frage ist doch wo es eingesetzt wird die
Schuldenbremse ist ein ganz nachhaltiges
Instrument und ganz viele Dinge werden
in diesem Land nicht möglich gewesen
ohne die Schuldenbremse und ohne die
Einhaltung der schwarzen Null 2014 der
Kollege Schreiner hat gesagt wir hatten
zum ersten Mal seit 1969 einen
ausgeglichenen Haushalt das hat ganz
viel ermöglicht ich möchte Ihnen sagen
ich bin auf diese Errungenschaft stolz
und ich möchte auch dass die
Schülerinnen und Schüler der Realschule
aus Weissach die jetzt gerade oben sind
auf der Tribüne dass sie auch stolz sind
weil das wird Ihnen helfen künftig auch
Handlungsspielräume zu haben damit bin
ich bei meinem zweiten Punkt
Nachhaltigkeit und das permanente Städte
größere leistungsversprechende Staates
das passt halt nicht zusammen der
Bundesrechnungshof sagt der Haushalt ist
versteinert unserem Rande seiner
Tragfähigkeit und sie satteln weitere
Dinge drauf sie satteln das Bürgergeld
drauf mit und nehme das wichtige
Incentive zur Aufnahme von Arbeit weg
warum tun sie das das wissen die ganze
Welt weiß das so wirtschaftlich
funktioniert Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe ja
aber untergraben sie doch nicht die
Motivation derer die jeden Tag aufstehen
und zur Arbeit gehen die Menschen werden
die Menschen werden sehr genau
ausrechnen ab wann es sich lohnt und vor
allem für eine Familie mit zwei Kindern
lohnt es sich nicht mehr zu arbeiten
wenn 3.500 Euro verdient wird es tut mir
leid ich kann sie nicht ich kann es
ihnen nicht ersparen wenn man über
Nachhaltigkeit spricht muss man über die
Nachhaltigkeit der Maßnahmen sprechen
die sie hier treffen wir haben
wir haben Krieg in Europa und eine
schwere Wirtschaftskrise wir müssen mit
Verlust an Märkten rechnen und an
Arbeitsplätzen und sie satteln in dieser
Situation noch höhere Sozialabgaben
drauf sie ignorieren den Handlungsbedarf
etwa bei der Rentenversicherung die ja
demografischen Handlungsbedarf hat das
wissen wir seit Jahren bitte handeln Sie
sie sind jetzt dran das gleiche gilt für
die Pflegeversicherung da sehe ich mit
großem Kummer wie die häusliche Pflege
im Verhältnis zur stationären Pflege
vernachlässigt wird und schlechter
gestellt wird auch da wäre es schön im
Sinne der Nachhaltigkeit für die
künftigen Generationen wenn an dem Punkt
etwas passieren würde ihre Analysen sind
schon ein bisschen unterkomplex und die
Maßnahmen nicht auf der Höhe der
Probleme wenn wir hier ein Festvortrag
hören und fässlich miteinander umgehen
dann kann man das so machen aber ich bin
schon auch dafür dass wir die wahren
Probleme ansprechen sonst fragen sich
die Menschen auch wir wirklich von dem
anderen Stern kommen
ich möchte meinen dritten Punkt
anbringen nämlich Politik beginnt mit
dem Betrachten der Wirklichkeit Erwin
Teufel der frühere
baden-württembergische Ministerpräsident
hat das immer gesagt das heißt
Prioritäten setzen statt Schulden machen
sie müssen den Koalitionsvertrag in
diese Zeit anpassen in Teilen neu fassen
damit die zeitenwände auch in diesem
Papier und in den Köpfen aller in der
Fraktion in der Regierungsfraktion
ankommt nachhaltigkeit ist ohne Mut
nicht zu machen Frau greste gestatten
sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkung aus der Fraktion
den fahrt bitte nicht gut Nachhaltigkeit
darf nicht zu einem radikalen
Geschäftsmodell verkommen wie wir das in
der Praxis auch mit der Taxonomie sehen
ganze Wirtschaftsbereiche werden von
frischem Kapital abgeschnitten und
ausgetrocknet die Folgen werden wir alle
zusammen ausbaden müssen Nachhaltigkeit
muss ein politisches Konzept sein dass
den Wandel organisiert und möglich macht
und dazu fordern wir Sie auf die nächste
Krise ist immer die schwierigste ohne
Prioritäten bleibt mehr als die
Nachhaltigkeit auf der Strecke nämlich
das Vertrauen der Menschen danke
war das aus der Unionsfraktion ist
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Bildung
Forschung und Technik Folgen Abschätzung
hat hier sich aber vor allem eingelassen
an zu Themen wie der Schuldenbremse der
schwarzen Null und aus ihrer Sicht hier
und dazu hohen Sozialleistungen Johannes
Wagner ist der nächste Redner und
stellvertretender Vorsitzender im
Unterausschuss globale Gesundheit
Liebe Kollege Brinkhaus
ihr Rede was er laut und durchaus
engagiert kann aber nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass ihre Politik in den
letzten Jahren nur heiße Luft war ich
möchte mal daran erinnern dass wir das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gebraucht haben
um sie daran zu erinnern dass sie in
ihrer Politik auch die Bedürfnisse von
jungen Menschen berücksichtigen müssen
ich will in die Debatte einsteigen mit
einer Frage die eckart von Hirschhausen
und Abgeordneten vor drei Wochen
gestellt hat als wir den parlamentskreis
one health gegründet haben er hat
gefragt was werden uns unsere
Enkelkinder eher verzeihen
temporär gestiegene Benzinpreise oder
dauerhaft gestiegene Meeresspiegel
nachhaltigkeit ist ein trendwort
geworden das Mega-Thema alles war
mittlerweile nachhaltig sein
nachhaltig investieren nachhaltig Reisen
selbst nachhaltige SUVs
es scheint fast so als müssten wir
nichts ändern der technische Fortschritt
wird es schon irgendwie richten
schaut man aber auf die Fakten müssen
wir kennen das stimmt leider nicht
Effizienzgewinne werden aufgefressen vom
Rebound-Effekt und die weltweiten
CO2-Emissionen sie steigen weiter schon
heute hat die globale Erderwärmung über
1,1 Grad zugenommen
die Folgen erleben die direkt bei uns
vor der Haustür
bei mir in Bayern gab es vor ein paar
Tagen die Meldung Bayern verliert einen
von fünf Gletschern Liebe CSU werfen ein
Anlass endlich die 10h-regel
abzuschaffen
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
müssen nicht die Gletscher retten wir
müssen auch nicht die Eisbären retten
nicht einmal die Erde wir müssen uns
retten denn die Klimakrise ist die
größte Bedrohung für die menschliche
Gesundheit in diesem Jahrhundert
und das sagen nicht ich das sage nicht
ich gesagt die WHO die Welt gehört
Organisation
allein in Deutschland sind dieses Jahr
wieder über 1.000 Menschen an den Folgen
von Hitze gestorben
Allergie nehmen zu und Tropenkrankheiten
breiten sich auch bei uns aus
wenn wir hier an der Spree Fälle von
West nilfieber haben dann stimmt doch
was nicht
die Klimakrise ist eine Gesundheitskrise
und deswegen werden wir SDG 3 Gesundheit
ohne SDG 310 Klimaschutz auch niemals
erreichen denn Gesundheit und Klima sind
untrennbar miteinander verbunden
dieser Zusammenhang ist aber nicht nur
negativ ganz im Gegenteil bietet auch
Chancen ich möchte kurz drei nennen
erstens eine echte mobilitätswende ist
nicht nur gut fürs Klima sie senkt auch
die Zahl der derzeit 70.000 Menschen die
alleine in Deutschland jährlich
vorzeitig an den Folgen von
Luftverschmutzung versterben
gleichzeitig ist Fahrradfahren und
laufen auch gut für unser
Herz-Kreislauf-System wer vom Auto aufs
Fahrrad wechselt gewinnt statistisch
bist du 14 Monate Lebenszeit wir
brauchen die mobilitätswende also für
das Klima und für die Gesundheit
zweitens
eine echte ernährungswende ist derzeit
wichtiger denn je die Art wie wir Tiere
halten und die Menge an Tieren die wir
essen treibt die Klimakrise an
gleichzeitig erhöhen Antibiotika die wir
in der Massentierhaltung einsetzen das
Risiko für multiresistente Keime ein
Umschwenken auf einen nachhaltige
Ernährung schützt nicht nur das Klima
und Biodiversität sie ist auch elementar
für unsere Gesundheit
und drittens der Sommer hat es erneut
gezeigt wie wichtig eine echte bauwende
ist
klimabedingte Hitzetage die sich
mittlerweile häufen heizen unsere Städte
auf es bilden sich hitze-inseln die bis
zu 10 Grad heißer sind als das Umland
deswegen brauchen wir
grünflächenpfadversiegelung Brunnen
statt Parkplätze und Bäume statt
Betonwüsten
und das ist nicht nur eine Frage von
Lebensqualität sondern auch das
Überlebens denn gerade in Städten ist
Hitze besonders tödlich
das zeigt wenn wir nachhaltig bauen sind
wir machen wir auch was gutes für unsere
Gesundheit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei
Klimaschutz und Gesundheit gibt es also
zum Glück kein entweder oder sondern ein
sowohl als auch
und um auf meine Eingangsfrage
zurückzukommen
um auf meine Eingangsfrage zurück zu
kommen wenn wir die volle Dimension von
Nachhaltigkeit verstehen und danach
handeln denn lautet die Antwort auf
gestiegene Meeresspiegel oder gestiegene
Benzinpreise
trockene Küstenstädte mit gutem ÖPNV
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion Kai
Gottschalk
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
verehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Zuschauer auf den Tribünen ich muss auf
einige Irrungen hier noch mal eingehen
Nachhaltigkeit gibt es schon immer sie
kennen den Spruch unsere Kinder sonst
mal besser haben als wir vielleicht
liegts daran dass sie einfach eine
kinderlose Gesellschaft in die Welt mit
ihrer schlechten Politik gesetzt haben
aber lasse mich auf meinem Punkt kommen
Finanzen sind sehr wichtig in der
Nachhaltigkeit aber einem Kollegen der
FDP klang es so ganz kurz mal an aber
ich sage einfach mal denn es steht und
fällt alles mit dem Gelder oder dem
europäischen green Deal hier mal als
Stichwort zu nennen der ja so Ressourcen
schon angeblich und energieschont mein
Kollege Kraft hat eben dargelegt wie man
so schön ideologisch alles färben kann
nachhaltig uns eine schöne grüne Welt
beschert die Folgen sehen Sie heute sie
haben es von Frau Scheer und anderen
hier gehört der Strom ist teurer
geworden seit wir diese sogenannte
ökologische Wende vollziehen wir haben
den teuersten Strom in der Welt und das
liegt nicht an ihrer grünen Energie
sondern das liegt an ihrer Schächten
Energiepolitik die sie insgesamt im
Energiemix betrieben haben meine Damen
und Herren
aber kommen wir zum finanzthema die
hochgelobte eu-taxonomie ich fasse mal
zusammen als Stichwort für Sie sie haben
es mitbekommen dort auf den Tribünen
Stichwort Kernkraft und Gast ist
nachhaltig Öl und Kohle nicht darin
sehen Sie schon an einer Taxonomie Liebe
Regierung auch bei ihnen wie Ideologie
getrieben und falsch ihre sogenannte
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie ist meine Damen
und Herren
in Wirklichkeit geht es Ihnen mit diesen
Regeln auch der Eigenkapitalunterlegung
von Banken von Kapitalsammelstellen und
Versicherung doch nur darum auch die
Kontrolle über die Wirtschaft und die
Finanzen zu bekommen zu bestimmen welche
Investition es gut und welche ist böse
das kann am besten aber der Unternehmer
weil der ist auf Effizienz getrimmt
meine Damen und Herren und auf wettbeweg
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und die brauchen
wir für die deutsche Wirtschaft aber
kein Sozialismus aller grüner Natur
meine Damen und Herren
Gelenke und gesteuerte Wirtschaft das
ist das Schlagwort unserer Zeit deswegen
das dritte Rettungspaket und ich
prognostizierte weil zum unzulänglich
ist müssen Sie noch ein viertes machen
meine Damen und Herren wir vertrauen auf
die Freiheit auch der Märkte denn der
Investor trägt auch schlecht schließlich
das Risiko und das haben Sie mit der
Finanzkrise 2009 aus der Kraftgesetz sie
haben nämlich Gewinne sozusagen
privatisiert und Verluste sozialisiert
und seitdem kommen sie aus dieser
sozialistischen Nummer nicht mehr raus
meine Damen und Herren
nachhaltigkeit ist ein weites Feld man
kann das Verfolgen an dieser Debatte die
hier seit 9 Uhr stattfindet und das war
kein Gottschalk aus der afd-fraktion sie
merken es sind jetzt die Finanzpolitiker
dran
vorübergehend aber wir werden hier in
den nächsten Stunden auch noch weitere
Aspekte beleuchten
Themen im Blick haben aktuell werde ich
oft gefragt warum ich mich bei
Energiekrise Krieg in Europa und
Inflation überhaupt mit dem Thema Rente
beschäftige soweit in die Zukunft zu
schauen ist aktuell nicht für jeden
naheliegend jetzt wo es so viel
wichtigere und drängende Themen gibt die
Energiekrise darf aus dem Dauerbrenner
Rente allerdings keine Sparflamme machen
es wird immer Probleme geben die akuter
sind
trotzdem müssen wir aufhören uns von der
Verantwortung gegenüber nachfolgenden
Generationen zu ducken das wäre mal
nachhaltig die Klima und die
Rentenpolitik Teilen traurige Schicksal
jahrzehntelang waren sie geprägt von
einer nach mir die sintflutmentalität
und das darf in dieser Legislaturperiode
nicht wieder passieren die Grundidee des
umlagefinanzierten Systems passt nicht
zu unserer Demografie es ist nicht
nachhaltig und das weiß man seit
Jahrzehnten der altersquotient also das
Verhältnis von meltische und hier im
Reichstagsgebäude wird wieder über die
langfristigen Themen diskutiert über die
langfristigen Probleme Lösungen nicht
über kurzfristige Vorhersagen es geht um
die im nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie um die
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien wir haben hier
verschiedene Aspekte schon gehört in den
vergangenen
knapp anderthalb Stunden die diese
Debatte läuft weitere anderthalb Stunden
wird sie auch mindestens noch dauern
fürs gab einen sehr interessanten
Redebeitrag von Ralf Brinkhaus aus der
Unionsfraktion der dieses Thema die
Kurzsichtigkeit in der auch die Politik
gelegentlich handelt dass sie die
langfristigen Ziele gelegentlich aus den
Augen verliert weil ein serieller
Alarmismus vorherrscher so hat er es
vorhin formuliert in seinem Redebeitrag
und hat dabei am Rande auch die Medien
erwähnte die dann die langfristigen
Themen die langfristigen Problemlösungen
gelegentlich ein wenig außer Acht lassen
jetzt wie gesagt aber hier noch die
Debatte zur Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie im
Moment sind Finanzpolitiker am Pol zum
Beispiel Anja Schulz aus der
FDP-Fraktion
gegeben der freie Entscheidungen
möglichst und bei dem der Taschenrechner
nicht zu dem Ergebnis kommt dass sich
Arbeit im Alter nicht mehr lohnt
unsere rentenpolitischen Forderungen
sind nicht nur ein wichtiger Schritt für
eine nachhaltige Finanzierung sondern
vor allem das Signal an junge Menschen
an nachfolgende Generationen dass sie
dem Staat vertrauen können das
Generationengerechtigkeit so wie es
bisher war nicht nur eine Phrase bleibt
sondern wirklich gelebt wird alle Bürger
auch wenn sie noch nicht wählen können
haben ein Recht darauf von der Politik
geachtet zu werden das ist nachhaltig
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Anke domscheitberg und Anke
domscheidtberg ist Sprecherin für
digitalpolitik in der Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen
wenn wir von Nachhaltigkeit reden müssen
wir auch vom Zusammenhang zwischen
Klimakrise und Digitalisierung reden wo
Digitalisierung Teil des Problems aber
auch der Lösung ist Energie und
Verkehrswende gehen gar nicht ohne
Digitalisierung und wir weg wollen vom
Individualverkehr und hin zum
bedarfsgerechten ÖPNV heißt das auch
dass ich mir einen Minibus auf Abruf
über eine App im ländlichen Raum in
Niedersachsen oder Brandenburg bestellen
kann aber Digitalisierung ist eben auch
Teil des Problems der
Ressourcenverbrauch ist enorm vor allem
auch bei der Herstellung elektronischer
Geräte bei unseren Handys zum Beispiel
sind drei Viertel der CO2-Emissionen
allein auf die Herstellung
zurückzuführen laut greenpeace-daten und
wenn wir alle unsere Smartphones statt
durchschnittlich drei Jahren Europa vier
Jahre verwenden würden könnten wir zwei
Millionen Tonnen CO2 in Europa einsparen
der Neukauf wird aber leider oft
erzwungen weil man die Akkus nicht
vernünftig wechseln kann und weil es
keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr gibt
deshalb hoffe ich dass die Ampel das
angekündigte Recht auf Reparatur und die
mindest updatepflicht langjährige
Forderungen der Linksfraktion auch zügig
umsetzt
aber die Bundesregierung hat zweifach
Verantwortung nicht nur als Regulierer
sondern auch als Großverbraucher für
über eine Milliarde Euro kauft der Bund
jedes Jahr it ein und der
Energieverbrauch der Bundes-IT könnte
mit seinen 335 Gigawattstunden
134.000 zwei Personen Haushalte
versorgen deshalb habe ich eine kleine
Anfrage zur Nachhaltigkeit der Bundes-IT
gestellt und ganz frisch zurückbekommen
die Antwort kam leider mit sehr vielen
Lehrstellen 2/3 der 184 Rechenzentren
des Bundes konnten nicht mal sagen ob
sie erneuerbare Energie benutzen ob die
IT nach der einkaufsrichtlinie auch
tatsächlich nachhaltig eingekauft wurde
keine Ahnung es gibt ja kein Monitoring
die Datenqualität war außerdem wirklich
mangelhaft es gab viele falsche Angaben
und auch widersprüchliche beim BMI haben
Rechenzentren Kälte kälteschädliche
Kältemittel als umweltfreundlich
bezeichnet das zeigt das übrigens
ziemlich kaputt und die datenkompetenz
mangelhaft
immerhin meine Kleine Anfrage hat bei
der Ampel auch etwas angestoßen nämlich
eine Vereinheitlichung und Erweiterung
des Berichtswesens zur Nachhaltigkeit in
der IT wurde noch während der
Beantwortung der Kleinen Anfrage
beschlossen das zeigt linke Opposition
wirkt
da wo es Daten gab war die
Nachhaltigkeit erschreckend schlecht
nicht einmal jedes zehnte Rechenzentrum
nutzt die Abwärme und nicht einmal jedes
dritte nutzt erneuerbare Energien nur
ein einziges der 184 Rechenzentren
erfüllt die Kriterien das blauen Engels
für Rechenzentren aber zwei Drittel
nutzen klimaschädliche Kältemittel es
soll jetzt eine energieeffizienzregister
für Rechenzentren in Deutschland kommen
aber die dateneintragung ist wohl nur
freiwillig und das fürchte ich wird
nichts bringen
die Ampel will sich nach ihrer
digitalstrategie daran messen lassen
dass Methoden energieeffizienter
Softwareentwicklung etabliert sind das
finde ich super denn ineffizient
ineffiziente Software verursacht viermal
so viel Energieverbrauch wie effiziente
aber der Bund der selbst sehr viel
Software entwickelt oder Entwicklung
beauftragt hat nicht eine einzige
Software die mit dem Blauen Engel für
Energieeffizienz ausgezeichnet ist auch
sonst weiß sie nichts darüber denn es
gibt keine Verbindlichkeit und keine
einheitlichen Vorgaben sie hat keine
Ahnung vom Status im eigenen Haus aber
auch die it-konsolidierung bleibt ein
Problemfall sie sollte zur
Nachhaltigkeit beitragen durch eine
Reduktion der bundesrechenzentren ihre
Anzahl aber das Milliardengrab wird
jetzt auch zur Hürde von nachhaltiger it
ja die Anzahl der Rechenzentren steigt
einfach immer weiter auch in den
nächsten Jahren wie immer gilt schöne
Ziele nutzen nichts wenn es am Ende an
Umsetzungskompetenz fehlt ich bin
trotzdem gespannt auf die angekündigten
Maßnahmepläne zur klimaneutralen
Bundesverwaltung und zur green
it-initiative als linke Opposition sind
wir gerne bereit fachliche Expertise
dazu einzubringen denn die Klimakrise
erfordert gemeinsames Handeln vielen
Dank
danke domscheitelberg die Sprecherin für
digitalpolitik in der Linksfraktion und
wir schauen auf den nächsten Redner
Helmut Kleebank ist der Vorsitzende in
einem Gremium das nicht ganz so präsent
ist in der Öffentlichkeit aber heute
schon der ist nämlich Vorsitzender im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und er war
Bezirksbürgermeister in Spandau am
Montag fand die Jahrestagung des Rates
für nachhaltige Entwicklung statt in
allen Debatten an diesem Tag gab es rund
um die Nachhaltigkeit eine zentrale
generationenübergreifende gemeinsame
Botschaft es gab eine Forderung die
immer wieder deutlich erhoben wurde sie
lautete wir brauchen bei der Umsetzung
der vorhandenen Konzepte für
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften und
nachhaltiges Leben deutlich mehr Tempo
Tempo war der meist gewählte Begriff an
diesem Tag
und das war nicht die tempo-grenzung auf
der Autobahn gemeint
und das stimmt gemessen an dem
jahrelangen voll auf den wir hatten ist
zu wenig wirksames passiert denn bereits
vor sieben Jahren im September 2015
verabschiedeten die Staats- und
Regierungschef der 193 Mitgliedsstaaten
der Vereinten Nationen die Agenda 2030
mit ihren 17 Nachhaltigkeitszielen vor
drei Jahren im September 19 kamen
ebenfalls die Staats- und
Regierungschefs zu dem Ergebnis dass
diese 17 Systeme bei Development Goals
verfehlt werden wenn sich die zu diesem
Zeitpunkt aktuellen Trends fortsetzen
daraufhin haben die Vereinten Nationen
bei ihrem sdg-gipfel das Jahrzehnt der
2020er Jahre zur aktionsdekade erklärt
auch die Bundesregierung erkennt dieses
Ziel an und arbeitet mit der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie für das
Erreichen dieser Ziele wir haben dazu
einiges gehört hier im Parlament wurde
in den vergangenen Monaten in allen
Bereichen eine große Zahl von Gesetzen
verabschiedet die beim Zeichen der sdgs
auf jeden Fall helfen werden ich
persönlich bin stolz darauf eine
Parlament anzugehören das Nachhaltigkeit
nicht nur verbal ernst nimmt sondern mit
großem Einsatz und inzwischen auch mit
deutlich mehr Tempo in die Tat umsetzt
allerdings
und jetzt kommt der Wermutstropfen
stelle ich fest dass wir uns als
Parlament immer noch einige Defizite
leisten blinde Flecken sozusagen die wir
uns meines Erachtens nicht leisten
sollten ich will das kurz begründen und
benennen die Beschäftigung mit den 70
Nachhaltigkeitszielen zeigt ganz
unschwer dass sie eng miteinander
verknüpft sind in zum Teil sehr
unterschiedlicherweise bedingen oder
beeinflussen sie sich gegenseitig die
Bundesregierung hat dieser Tatsache mit
der Formulierung von und der
Konzentration auf 6 sogenannte
transformationsbereiche Rechnung
getragen auch das ist vorgetragen worden
jeder transformationsbereich adressiert
eine Gruppe von sdgs die untereinander
in besonders engem Zusammenhang stehen
im Deutschen Bundestag wird diese
Tatsache dieser sinnvolle vernetzte
Ansatz bislang unzureichend abgebildet
ein zweiter blinder Fleck die schnelle
und wirksame Bekämpfung der globalen
Krisen wie zum Beispiel der Erderwärmung
des Artensterbens oder der
Überschwemmung des Planeten mit
Plastikmüll
gelingt nur mit einem internationalen
Kraftakt und auf dieser internationalen
Bühne auch das wurde von den
internationalen Gästen unter anderem von
wellen-generalsekretärin
Johnson surf der
friedensnobelpreisträgerinnen und
ehemaligen Präsident Liberias am Montag
sehr deutlich gemacht auf der
internationalen Bühne wird sehr genau
auf die Transformation in Deutschland
und auf Deutschlands Rolle der globalen
Transformation geachtet
in diesen beiden Aspekten der Arbeit an
den transformationsbereichen und der
Wechselwirkung zwischen nationalem und
internationalem handeln muss sich der
Deutsche Bundestag meines Erachtens
selbst ertüchtigen wie komme ich zu
dieser Einschätzung der parlamentarische
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung der
für all diese Fragen das prädestinierte
Gremium darstellt hat bislang weder den
Status noch die faktischen Möglichkeiten
in diesen übergreifenden Fragen
gegenüber der Regierung in besonderer
Weise für das Parlament wirksam zu
werden wenn wir uns im September
nächsten Jahres mit dem Zwischenbericht
des pbnb beschäftigen wird dieser
Bericht auch Vorschläge für die
Weiterentwicklung des Beirats enthalten
lassen Sie uns als Parlament gemeinsam
daran arbeiten und dafür sorgen dass er
auch Antworten auf die hier
aufgefrorenen aufgeworfenen Fragen
enthält und dass wir diese dann auch
gemeinsam in die Tat umsetzen vielen
Dank
Helmut Kleeberg der Vorsitzende des
parlamentarischen Beirats für
nachhaltige Entwicklungen falls Sie über
eine Abkürzung eine englische gestolpert
sein sollten es die GS hat er gesagt die
wörtliche bedeutet wörtliche Sustainable
Development Goals also nichts anderes
als Nachhaltigkeitsziele nach Helmut
klebe an dem Vorsitzenden des
parlamentarischen Beirats jetzt der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende eben dieses
Gremiums Wolfgang stefinger wollen
Arbeit und Wohlstand jedoch ohne ihre
Lebensgrundlagen zu zerstören die
anderen wollen den Wohlstand erhalten
und ausbauen und müssen dies
nachhaltiger tun als bisher wenn wir
heute über Nachhaltigkeit sprechen so
müssen wir einen Blick auf Entwicklungs-
und Schwellenländer richten denn zur
Wahrheit gehört unser Wohlstand ist eng
mit Entwicklungsländern verknüpft
es gibt ja immer wieder Stimmen die
meinen Entwicklungsländer gingen uns
nichts an das ist ein fataler Irrtum wir
haben nämlich alle täglich mit
Entwicklungsländern zu tun haben sie
heute morgen einen Kaffee getrunken wo
kommen die Bohnen her
haben Sie vielleicht die Jeans angezogen
wo wird die Baumwolle angebaut und wo
wir diese Kleidung genäht können die
näher davon leben die Bestandteile der
Batterien für die Handys für die E-Autos
für die Laptops wo kommt das Kobalt her
das Lithium die Liste ließe sich also
beliebig fortsetzen
2014 wurden die 17 Nachhaltigkeitsziele
beschlossen mit dem Ziel diese bis 2030
auch zu erreichen doch wo stehen wir wir
haben es heute auch schon gehört
Stichwort Armutsbekämpfung Kampf gegen
Hunger die Zahlen steigen wieder auch
durch Corona beim Thema Umweltschutz und
Erhalt der Biodiversität haben wir
Nachholbedarf beim Thema bezahlbare und
saubere Energie weltweit sind tausende
Kohlekraftwerke geplant gehen sie ans
Netz ist die Erreichung des
zweigrad-ziels unmöglich meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren diese
Beispiele sollen verdeutlichen warum wir
das Thema Nachhaltigkeit nicht isoliert
Weihnachten können nicht nur auf
Deutschland bezogen nicht nur auf Europa
bezogen sondern weltweit wir müssen
begreifen dass wir eine Welt sind und
für sie alle gemeinsam Verantwortung
tragen deshalb
deshalb möchte ich auch drei Gedanken
nennen wie wir gemeinsam als eine Welt
nachhaltiger werden können erster Punkt
Entwicklungssprünge ermöglichen und
nutzen was heißt das für
Entwicklungsländer geht es nicht darum
Entwicklungen unsere Entwicklungen
nachzuholen sondern es geht darum
Entwicklungsschritte auch zu
überspringen und direkt auf neue auf
Umwelt auf klimafreundliche Technologien
auf nachhaltige Technologien zu setzen
und wer wenn nicht wir wer wenn nicht
unser Wissenschaft unsere Wirtschaft
könnte hier unterstützen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in Afrika
wächst die Bevölkerung am schnellsten
und wird sich bis 2050 sogar verdoppeln
bereits heute haben auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent 600 Millionen
Menschen keinen Zugang zu Strom
in Afrika wird in den kommenden zehn
Jahren so viel gebaut werden wie in
Europa in den vergangenen hundert Jahren
gebaut wurde die Fragen sind also ob der
Strom aus fossilen oder erneuerbaren
Quellen erzeugt wird ob mit Stahl und
Beton oder mit nachwachsenden Rohstoffen
gebaut wird auch darüber oder auch daran
wird sich entscheiden ob sich der
Klimawandel Bremsen lässt oder nicht
deshalb sage ich ganz deutlich
Nachhaltigkeit
Nachhaltigkeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist Entwicklungspolitik oder
anders gesagt Entwicklungspolitik ist
weltweite
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik und das hier
gespart wird in diesem Etat ist das
falsche Signal der Bundesregierung
die
die Union meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren hat in den vergangenen 16 Jahren
hier eine Vielzahl auf den Weg gebracht
Stichwort energiepartnerschaften
Frau Künast vielleicht nehmen wir mal
ein paar Baldriantropfen dass sie ein
bisschen ruhiger werden
hat wirklich einiges auf den Weg
gebracht Stichwort
energiepartnerschaften diese gilt es
auszubauen diese gilt es zu stärken
Afrika könnte rechnerisch ganz Europa
mit Solarenergie versorgen wieso nutzen
Sie liebe Bundesregierung die aktuelle
Krise nicht um diese Partnerschaften
auch zu stärken liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das größte Solarkraftwerk der
Welt in Marokko ist ein gutes Beispiel
ein Beispiel für gemeinsame
Investitionen ein Beispiel für
internationale Zusammenarbeit ein
Beispiel wie Technik unter anderem aus
Deutschland einen Beitrag zur
Nachhaltigkeit leisten kann ich sage
Ihnen eines wir brauchen mehr davon
zweiter Gedanke
es braucht auch und wir sehen das ja wie
eng wir verbunden sind die Welt ist ein
globales Dorf alleine auch was die
Lieferketten betrifft es braucht auch
faire Lieferketten es braucht Fernhandel
und faire Produktion aber fair darf kein
Nachteil sein für die Unternehmen
sondern es muss ein Vorteil sein und
deswegen müssen wir dieses Thema auch in
internationalen Abkommen die man im
übrigen auch wollen muss Liebe grüne
auch entsprechend müssen diese Abkommen
auch Regeln enthalten und auch die
europäische Handelspolitik muss einen
Beitrag zu diesen Nachhaltigkeitszielen
leisten wir als Union haben in der
letzten Wahlperiode einen ersten
wichtigen Schritt mit unserem
lieferkettengesetz gemacht
Dritter Gedanke
Dritter Gedanke es braucht weltweite
Standards nachhaltigkeit bedeutet auch
globale Güter zu schützen und
Verantwortung für das Gemeinwohl zu
übernehmen die Politik kann Regeln
festsetzen dass es klar aber es kommt
auch auf uns alle an
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren bei
Nachhaltigkeit geht es um den Erhalt
unserer Lebensgrundlagen ökologisch
wirtschaftlich sozial und kulturell es
geht um Gerechtigkeit gegenüber Menschen
in anderen Teilen der Welt und gegenüber
kommenden Generationen es geht um
Chancengleichheit sozialen Zusammenhalt
und es geht um Frieden vielen Dank
Wolfgang stäfinger aus der
Unionsfraktion aber auch als
stellvertretender Vorsitzender des
parlamentarischen Beirats führen
nachhaltige Entwicklung hat noch mal
aufgezeigt wie groß und wie breit und
wie wichtig auch das Feld nachhaltigkeit
ist und dass es tatsächlich nicht nur um
Umwelt und Naturschutz geht nächster
Redner wird sein Jan Niklas gesenhus wer
ist in der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Sprecher für Umwelt und
Naturschutz
Kolleginnen und Kollegen man konnte sich
heute bei den unionsreden Live angucken
was es bedeutet sich in schlankenfuß zu
machen und ich will ihn mal eins sagen
was ich noch nie leiden konnte was ich
noch nie leiden konnte ist sich über
Jahre mal so richtig austoben ein
riesensausstall zu hinterlassen und dann
den anderen zu sagen so jetzt macht das
mal bitte schon weg übernehmen sie
endlich mal Verantwortung für das was
sie in ihrer Regierungszeit gemacht
haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
brauchen eine ambitionierte
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik um noch lange
frei und sicher auf diesem Planeten
leben zu können es geht um unsere
Freiheit und es geht um unsere
Sicherheit um nichts weniger
und richtig ist dafür braucht es alle
drei Säulen der Nachhaltigkeit Umwelt
Wirtschaft und Soziales aber war es auch
diese drei Säulen der Nachhaltigkeit
sind auch nicht einfach unbegrenzt
miteinander austauschbar und ich will
das mal sehr deutlich sagen sie können
Ökosystemleistungen sie können die
Leistung der Natur Wasserhaushalt
Luftreinhaltung Artenvielfalt die können
sie nicht einfach technisch ersetzen das
ist unmöglich und dieses Bewusstsein
fehlt ganz oft und das ist Teil des
Problems und das genau das ist auch Teil
des Problems in ihrem Antrag Liebe
Unionsfraktion weil wenn ich mir das mal
so angucke was sie da in ihren
Forderungen ausschreiben dann lese ich
dann nichts zum Naturschutz nichts zur
Biodiversität und nicht mal was zu
Wasserkrise nach diesem dürresommer das
ist einfach schwach Liebe Union
und weil dieses Bewusstsein so fehlt
überschreiten wir unsere planetaren
Grenzen massiv Staatssekretärin Hoffmann
hat vorhin darauf hingewiesen und durch
dieses Überschreiten der planetaren
Belastungsgrenzen schränken wir unsere
Freiheit ein und unsere Sicherheit ein
und zwar nicht wie manche das
suggerieren durch neue Gesetze und neue
Regeln sondern durch eine dramatische
über Nutzung unserer natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen das sehen wir beim
Flächenverbrauch das sehen wir bei der
rohstoffausbeutung das sehen wir auch
beim dramatischen Zustand der Meere und
Wälder und damit müssen wir Schluss
machen meine Damen und Herren mehr
Nachhaltigkeit um unsere Freiheit und
unsere Sicherheit auch für kommende
Generationen zu sichern
und ich will das auch ganz deutlich
sagen das gilt auch gerade jetzt in der
Krise
Angriffe auf Umwelt und Naturschutz
jetzt in der Krise sozusagen die Krise
dafür zu instrumentalisieren das ist
völlig fehl am Platz lassen Sie das
bitte weil wir kriegen die Krise nicht
bekämpft durch Abstriche bei Umwelt und
Naturschutz sondern was in der Krise
hilft sind ernsthafte Vorschläge
Ernsthaftigkeit wirksame Konzepte und
keine ablenkungsdebatten lassen sie uns
zu Ernsthaftigkeit zurückkehren meine
Damen und Herren dann geben wir die
richtigen Antworten auf die Krise
und deswegen erhalten wir gerade jetzt
das was uns erhält und das was uns
erhält das ist ein global umspannendes
Netz der Arten und Ökosysteme und weil
wir in dieser massiven
biodiversitätskrise sind brauchen wir
globale antworten weil es eben auch eine
globale Krise ist und deswegen ist es
gut dass die Bundesregierung sich
einsetzt für ein ambitioniertes
Schutzabkommen für die Biodiversität für
ein Abkommen gegen die plastikvermüllung
für ein Abkommen für den Schutz auf
hoher See dass die Bundesregierung 1,5
Milliarden für die globale
biodiversitätsfinanzierung zur Verfügung
stellt und dass wir national vorangehen
mit vier Milliarden Euro für den
natürlichen Klimaschutz ich kann nur
sagen weiter so und ich freue mich wenn
daran auch alle wirklich alle Ressorts
mitmachen vielen Dank
sagt Jan Niklas gesenhues aus der
Fraktion Bündnis die 90 die Grünen ihm
wird jetzt
folgender aus der afd-fraktion wo er
auch entwicklungspolitischer Sprecher
ist
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Scholz Habeck und baerbock wollen nicht
zitiere aus der Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
der Bundesregierung den sozialen
Zusammenhalt stärken Armut überwinden
und inklusiven Wohlstand fördern Zitat
Ende wo hat das links gelbe Bündnis
Armut überwunden
wo haben sie inklusiven Wohlstand
geschaffen machen wir doch mal ein
Realitätscheck Lindner lässt auf Sylt
die Korken knallen Frau Lambrecht kehrt
mit dem Sohnemann in Berliner luxusclubs
ein Habeck gibt uns Tipps zum Duschen
und Frau baerbock stellt fremde
Interesse über deutsche Schaumwein und
Thomas für die
und Wollpullover für frierende Bürger
meine Damen und Herren
inklusiven Wohlstand fördert diese reg
nur für sich selber die Bürger in
Deutschland sind ihnen doch völlig egal
anstatt Nord Stream 2 zu öffnen lässt
diese Regierung zu das kritische
Infrastruktur in die Luft gesprengt wird
anstatt Kernkraftwerke weiter laufen zu
lassen führt diese Regierung einen
peinlichen Eiertanz auf um grüne
Phantasiewelten vor der Realität zu
schützen anstatt mit höchster Priorität
ein
inflationsschutzgesetz auszuarbeiten
schreibt diese Regierung lieber die
hundertste Neuauflage des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes damit wir im
Winter beim frieren auch noch Maske
tragen können
und anstatt sofort auf alle Maßnahmen
einzugehen und diese zu ergreifen damit
Bürger und Unternehmen ihren Strom und
ihre Gasrechnungen zahlen können
verschenken sie auch dieses Mal wieder
11 Milliarden Euro
Entwicklungsleistungen ins Ausland auf
inklusiven Wohlstand für die Damen und
Herren der Regierung verzichten wir
gerne wenn es dafür wieder Politik mit
exklusiven Bezug zu Realität gibt
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Jens teutrine und er ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales und
Sprecher für Bürgergeld auch das Jahr
ein Aspekt von Nachhaltigkeit allen
Reden gehört es gibt mehrere Dimensionen
der Nachhaltigkeit wir haben nicht nur
die ökologische Nachhaltigkeit sondern
selbstverständlich auch die Frage
ökonomischer und sozialer Nachhaltigkeit
die sind auch in den 17 Zielen der
Verhalten Nationen festgeschrieben und
ein Aspekt ist ja auch die Bekämpfung
von Ungleichheit der da festgeschrieben
ist und da geht es auch um die Frage wie
ist denn die nachhaltige Sozialpolitik
gestaltet in unserem Land und es wurde
bereits angesprochen und ich erlebe das
auch immer wieder in Diskussionen dass
Sozialpolitiker dann als besonders
sozial Glauben zu gelten wenn Sie viel
Geld ausgeben gucken wir aber bereits in
der Verteilung des Geldes geben wir eine
Billion Euro in soziale Systeme in in
Deutschland bereits aus ein Drittel des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts fließt in die
verschiedenen Systeme von Rente bis
Gesundheit in den Sozialstaat rein und
deswegen glaube ich es eine nachhaltige
Sozialpolitik nicht daran gemessen
werden sollte wer mehr Geld ausgibt
sondern die Frage ist ist das Geld was
sich ausgebe auch wirksam bekämpft ist
ungleichheitsdimensionen
schafft es Aufstiegschancen für junge
Menschen oder zementiert ist obwohl ich
so viel Geld ausgebe eigentlich
weiterhin
ungleichheitern es ist wirklich Hilfe
zur Selbsthilfe oder mache ich einiges
vielleicht nur aus einem guten Gewissen
deswegen ist eine wichtige
nachhaltigkeitsdimension und der
Fortschritt von sozialer Politik misst
sich nicht am umverteilungsgrad sondern
an der Wirksamkeit von den Maßnahmen und
der Aufstiegschancen und dann und dann
ist es sehr prominent auch dann wenn es
um Ungleichheiten geht neue Steuern zu
fordern in den Glauben wenige
Superreiche besteuern zu können wird
dann sehr gerne die Vermögensteuer
wieder ins Spiel gebracht in der
jetzigen Situation eine Gefahr für die
Substanz des Mittelstandes in
Deutschland jetzt hier im deutschen
Rednerpult mehr Steuern und mehr
Steuerbelastung für Unternehmen und
Unternehmen zu fordern die haben nämlich
das Vermögen in den Betrieben und
ähnliches ist quasi gefährlich zu
glauben man könnte so vermö Ungleichheit
zu bekämpfen man muss die Debatte
vielleicht mal anders herumführen
nämlich die Frage zu stellen wieso haben
eigentlich so wenig Menschen mit einem
mittleren Einkommen Rücklagen für diese
Krise wieso haben sie in den letzten
Jahren kein Vermögen gebildet wieso ist
es in Deutschland so schwer möglich in
den letzten Jahren sich das Traum den
Traum von den alten den eigenen vier
Wänden zu ermöglichen also wir sollten
weniger darüber diskutieren vermeintlich
große Vermögen kleiner zu machen sondern
mittlere Einkommen zu Vermögensbildung
aufzurufen ist auch eine Frage der
Nachhaltigkeit und der Bekämpfung von
vermögensungleichheiten die Debatte
andersherum zu führen und viele junge
Menschen machen das die wissen dass das
dass das Rentensystem marode ist für sie
wir Zuschuss und ist schon mit 100
Milliarden 100 Milliarden Euro
Steuergelder fließen jedes Jahr ins
Rentensystem und wir wissen dass die
Demografie das noch weiter verschärfen
wird deswegen sparen junge Menschen in
ETF deswegen legen sie in Aktien ein und
wir sollten ihn Anreize schaffen
beispielsweise durch Spekulationsfrist
das auf einer Haltedauer von 10 20
Jahren man auch steuerfrei rauskommt
große
gesparfheitsfreibeträge also die Frage
von Nachhaltigkeit erschöpft sich nicht
nur in einer ökologischen Dimension oder
in linker Träumerei wo man seinen
Wahlprogramm immer wieder vorliest
sondern es ist notwendig eine vertiefte
Debatte zu führen als FDP stehen wir für
Vermögensaufbau wir stehen für
Aufstiegschancen und das werden wir in
dieser Koalition auch stark machen
vielen Dank
Jens teutrine mit sozialen und
sozialpolitischen Dimensionen des Themas
Nachhaltigkeit und er ist ja auch
Mitglied eben parlamentarischen Beirat
für nachhaltige Entwicklung genauso wie
Jakob Blankenburg aus der SPD-Fraktion
der jetzt spricht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Klimakrise artenkrise Hungerkrise
Energiekrise soziale Ungleichheit wir
haben jetzt von diesem redepult aus
schon viel gehört über die
vielschichtigen Krisen vor denen wir in
Deutschland aber vor denen wir auch als
gesamte Weltgemeinschaft stehen und
manche dieser Krisen die haben ihre
Wurzeln im angriffskriegs Russlands auch
die Ukraine andere die waren schon lange
da und ihre Effekte wurden durch den
Krieg noch mal verstärkt das gilt ganz
im besonderen Maße aber für die
Klimakrise und die nur schleppende
Umstellung der Energieversorgung von
fossilen auf erneuerbare Energie und
diese Klimakrise die trifft uns alle
aber ganz im speziellen die junge
Generation sie ist gleich doppelt
betroffen von dieser Klimakrise sie muss
zum einen besonders lange mit den
negativen Auswirkungen des Klimawandels
zurechtkommen und sie ist zum anderen
aus Sicht der Wissenschaft die letzte
Generation die noch in der Lage ist das
Ruder herumzureißen
sie ist gleichsam dazu verdammt will sie
ihre zukünftigen Lebensgrundlagen
schützen und wo immer man hinschaut da
drängen deshalb junge Menschen auch
Veränderungen sei es beim globalen
klimastreik am vergangenen Freitag
seines die Eingaben der jung-deligierten
beim high-level political forum on
substanable Development vergangenen
Sommer in New York oder die Beiträge der
Jugendverbände wir haben es heute schon
gehört bei der Jahrestagung des Rates
für nachhaltige Entwicklung am Montag
überall sind sich die jungen Menschen
einig das zu wenig passiert und dass wir
als Politikerinnen und Politiker zu
langsam sind auch der Identität
identifikatorenbericht 2021 der über den
Sachstand der Erreichung der Ziele für
nachhaltige Entwicklung Auskunft gibt
der zeigt für Deutschland ein eher
ausbaufähiges Bild bei zentralen
Entwicklungszielen oder kurz sdgs wie
Armut Hunger oder Ungleichheit da treten
wir auf der Stelle oder haben uns sogar
verschlechtert und dabei läuft uns die
Zeit davon wir haben nur noch acht Jahre
zu erreichtung der Ziele der Agenda 2030
und wir müssen uns jetzt bewegen
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen beim
Thema erneuerbare Energien der zeigen
wir aktuell dass das geht dass wir Tempo
machen können wir stellen die Weichen
für einen beschleunigten Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren und damit hin zu einer
klimaneutralen nachhaltigen
Energieerzeugung
aber wir müssen wir müssen das in mehr
Bereichen schaffen deutschland und die
anderen westlichen Industriestaaten
steht die stehen in der Verantwortung
beim Thema nachhaltige Entwicklung
voranzugehen wir haben unseren Wohlstand
zum Teil zu Lasten anderer Länder
aufgebaut ganz zu schweigen welchen
negativen Umweltauswirkungen unserer
wirtschaften und handeln bis heute hat
und blickt man auf die Auswirkungen der
eingangsgenannten Krisen dann stellen
die westlichen Entwicklung
Industriestaaten im Vergleich zu vielen
Schwellenländern und Entwicklungsländern
vergleichsweise gut da und deshalb
dürfen wir bei der Umsetzung von Klima
und Entwicklungszielen nicht nachlassen
ganz im Gegenteil wir müssen weiter
vorangehen und Vorbild sein auch um
andere Länder zu ambitionierte rapolitik
zu bewegen
und deshalb deshalb liegt Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ist es wichtig dass sich
die aktuelle Regierungskoalition als
fortschrittskoalition zum Thema
Nachhaltigkeit bekennt und sie bekennt
sich zu internationaler Zusammenarbeit
und zu Bewältigung globaler Krisen das
haben wir heute morgen auch schon von
entwicklungsministerin Schulze gehört
das hat Bundeskanzler oder Scholz auch
nochmals bei der UN-Generalversammlung
unterstrichen im Rahmen der Deutschen
g7-präsidentschaft haben wir uns auch
ganz konkret unter Beweis gestellt und
das Bündnis für Ernährungssicherheit und
den klimaklub initiiert
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
wir als Bundestag wir bekennen uns zum
Thema Nachhaltigkeit und deshalb müssen
wir als Parlament den Anspruch haben bei
Weichenstellungen in der Nachhaltigkeit
auch mit am Tisch zu sitzen wir haben
bislang den parlamentarischen Beirat für
nachhaltige Entwicklung als unser
Gremium dafür aber wie der Name schon
sagt hat das Gremium ein er begleitende
und beratenden Charakter hier müssen wir
uns als Parlament stärker einbringen und
ein wesentlichen zu
entschädigungsgremium auf ein
wesentliches wirkliches
Entscheidungsgremium hinwirken wie das
konkret aussehen kann das wird uns als
Deutscher Bundestag in den nächsten
Monaten beschäftigen
der hat uns auch heute schon Vorschläge
unterbreitet und ich komme zum Schluss
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue
mich auf die Debatte dazu dass wir als
Parlament wirklich ein Wachhund mit zehn
im Bereich der Nachhaltigkeit werden
daran arbeiten wir in den nächsten
Monaten vielen Dank
Jakob Blankenburg ob man im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung für den er mehr Kompetenzen
eingefordert hat das haben wir heute
schon öfter mal gehört hier im Bundestag
hat Yvonne Marc was die Sitzungsleitung
übernommen die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin der Bundestag
diskutiert noch bis ca 12:30 Uhr über
die nationale Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
und dazu ist jetzt am Pult Astrid
Damerow ob Frau im Ausschuss für Umwelt
und Naturschutz und Mitglied der
Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja es ist gut
dass wir die Nachhaltigkeit bei
politischen Entscheidungen in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten deutlich mehr
berücksichtigt haben aber gerade in der
Umwelt Landwirtschaft und
ernährungspolitik wird dabei auch
deutlich wie sehr diese Ziele sich
teilweise oder wie sehr diese Ziele
teilweise in einem Konflikt zueinander
stehen
beispielsweise fordert das Ziel Nummer
sechs Wasser für alle verfügbar zu
machen und
das Ziel 15 den der Schutz der
Landökosysteme
diese beiden
also Ziel Nummer sechs und Ziel Nummer
15 Schutz des Wassers und Schutz der
Landökosysteme sind ein
nachhaltigkeitsziel den wir uns
verpflichtet haben seit Jahren
unternehmen wir sehr viel um unsere
Gewässer zu schützen und unsere
ökologische Vielfalt zu erhalten und zu
verbessern alle Programme dazu fordern
aber auch beispielsweise unserer
Landwirtschaft eine Menge ab damit sind
wir beim nachhaltigkeitsziel 2 der
Ernährungssicherheit
Deutschland ist ein Kunststandort für
die Nahrungsmittelproduktion soll heißen
wir haben auch die Pflicht
Nahrungsmittel für Menschen in weniger
begünstigsten begünstigten Regionen der
Erde zu produzieren heißt also zwischen
den Nachhaltigkeitszielen Schutz des
Wassers und der Land Ökosysteme und im
Ziel Nummer zwei der
Ernährungssicherheit bestehen nicht
unerhebliche Konflikte die wir erstens
finde ich in den Debatten um unsere
Schutzprogramme deutlich klarer benennen
müssen
bei denen wir aber auch alles an
Innovationen nutzen müssen um diese
Ziele zu erreichen ich spreche hier mal
beispielsweise an die Debatte die wir
vor einiger Zeit hatten zur Nutzung
neuer genomischer Techniken zu Züchtung
von landwirtschaftlichen Nutzpflanzen
ein anderes Beispiel ist das sdsdg
Nummer 9 hier bekennen wir uns zu einer
widerstandsfähigen Infrastruktur und im
Ziel Nummer 11 zur sicheren und wieder
zu sicheren und widerstandsfähigen
Städten und Siedlung
verschiedene Hochwasserkatastrophen in
den vergangenen Jahren für uns aber
führen uns aber vor Augen dass wir
massive staatliche Investitionen in den
Hochwasserschutz vornehmen müssen ein
widerstandsfähiger Hochwasserschutz wird
aber auch Flächen in Anspruch nehmen
dies sind dann Flächen die wir nur noch
eingeschränkt für Siedlungen für
Landwirtschaft aber auch für den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien nutzen können
haben wir für diese Konflikte wirklich
schon antworten
im nachhaltigkeitsziel Nummer 14
fordern wir die nachhaltig die
nachhaltige Nutzung und Bewahrung
unserer Ozeane und Meere natürlich sie
sind Lebensraum für Fische Vögel
Pflanzen und sie sind unverzichtbar für
das Überleben der Menschheit das auch
deshalb hat Deutschland 45 Prozent
seiner Meeresgewässer unter Schutz
gestellt unsere Meere sind aber auch
Wirtschaftsräume für Fischerei für
Tourismus sie sind Handelswege es sind
Häfen die notwendig sind eben für den
Transport von Waren und Gütern
zusätzlich werden wir nun mit der
Offshore-Energie auch noch mehr
erneuerbare Energien auch in unseren
Meeren produzieren müssen denn die
Produktion von erneuerbaren Energien ist
ein Beitrag zum nachhaltigkeitsziel
Nummer 7 nachhaltige und moderne Energie
für alle zur Verfügung zu stellen
zugleich ist der Bau von
offshorwindanlagen aber ein massiver
Eingriff in das für Ökosystem unsere
Meere auch auf diese Konfliktsituation
brauchen wir Antworten die wir
ehrlicherweise noch nicht haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Beispiele belegen dass alle
Nachhaltigkeitsziele sich aufeinander
beziehen das ist heute schon
angesprochen worden soll heißen dass das
vollständige Erreichen eines
nachhaltigkeitszieles sofort massive
Konflikte mit dem Erreichen anderer
Ziele nach sich zieht um das in Einklang
zu bringen
wird uns viel abverlangt werden wir
werden wesentlich offener das hat die
Kollegin der FDP vorhin angesprochen wir
werden viel offener uns mit Innovationen
in allem Bereichen beschäftigen müssen
es darf dann auch keine Denkverbote
geben die wir alle zugegebenermaßen
mitunter auch reflexhaft haben ich hatte
vorhin schon das Thema der genomischen
Techniken angesprochen
ich denke die Debatte und die
Nachhaltigkeit wird immer wieder auch
wirklich zu politischen
Auseinandersetzungen führen und zwar
hier in unserem Parlament das ist
richtig und das ist auch wichtig und ich
will mich hier meinen Kollegen Ralf
Brinkhaus anschließen ich hätte mir sehr
gewünscht dass auch diese
Ampelkoalition wie in der Vergangenheit
auch sich dafür wirklich einen ganzen
Tag Zeit genommen hätte und jeder
Fachbereich das Thema Nachhaltigkeit
hätte ausgiebig diskutieren können denn
an den
an den wenigen Beispielen die ich gerade
aufgezählt habe wird ja deutlich dass es
wirklich sehr sehr komplex ist in allen
Fachbereichen und wir werden eigentlich
mit einer Debatte von drei Stunden der
Komplexität dieses Themas in keiner
Weise gerecht also möglicherweise ist
die Ampelkoalition in der Lage sich
vielleicht für nächstes Jahr ein anderes
Vorgehen zu überlegen das würde meine
Fraktion und mich sehr freuen vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
auch Astrid demmerow aus der
Unionsfraktion beklagt noch einmal das
die Zeit für diese
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte doch einigermaßen
übersichtlich bemessen ist sie ist zwar
für eine Debatte mit drei Stunden oder
fast dreieinhalb durchaus lang und
länger als hier der übliche Durchschnitt
aber wie gesagt zu Beginn der letzten
Legislaturperiode wurde sehr viel
intensiver über das Thema Nachhaltigkeit
diskutiert und dann auch zu den
einzelnen Ressorts der damaligen
Bundesregierung Stefan gelb war Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Istanbul Beitrag
auch die letzten Worte wir werden das
für das nächste Jahr sicherlich
berücksichtigen aber ich möchte mal eins
sagen erstens 2020
2019/2021 war das eben auch keine
nachhaltigkeitswoche wie der Kollege
Ralf Brinkhaus angesprochen hat ist
einfach nicht passiert und es ist auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht so dass wir eine
Erkenntnis oder wissensproblem haben wir
haben Umsetzungsprobleme und
und noch ein Schritt durch ich bin noch
eins sagen Richtung des Kollegen
Brinkhaus sie haben so wunderbar
formuliert ist immer mal was anderes
wichtiger ja das ist ja aber nicht von
hingefallen sondern das sind ja
menschengemachte Entscheidung dass immer
etwas anderes wichtiger war und für
diese Entscheidung gab es
Verantwortlichkeiten und gerade die
größte Fraktion der letzten Legislatur
hat doch da irgendeine Verantwortung
gehabt und ehrlich gesagt auch der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der größten
Fraktion hat doch dann eine
Verantwortung deswegen bin ich ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen irritierend wenn sie
nach vorne stellen und sagen alles wann
andere war irgendwie bisschen wichtiger
sorry heute ist deswegen sind wir nicht
so richtig Weiterkommen aber jetzt noch
mal richtig loslegen das ist ehrlich
gesagt aus einem Rost und Reiter auch
benennen das passt nicht aber gut
Vergangenheit ist alles Vergangenheit
aber trotzdem man muss es doch immer
einmal immer mal wieder andeuten wenn
das hier so vorgetragen wird aber
nochmal konkret Nachhaltigkeit und
Verkehr das erste Stichwort dazu ist ja
Klimaschutz und hier haben wir
Nachholbedarf nach vielen Jahren und
Jahrzehnten der Untätigkeit wir hoffen
dass da der Verkehrsminister im Rahmen
des Klimaschutz Sofortprogramms jetzt
ein Maßnahmenpaket vorliegen wird und
das ist mit der Erwartung verbunden von
uns zumindest dass das dann den
Klimaschutzzielen von Paris genügt nach
einem Jahr Ampelkoalition ist der
Koalitionsvertrag logischerweise noch
nicht abgearbeitet damit aber unsere
künftige Verkehrspolitik klimagerecht
ist brauchen wir den vereinbarten
klimaschek und das ist eine Aufgabe die
muss jetzt kommen
aber Nachhaltigkeit das ist ja nicht die
ganzen Redebeiträge schon durchgeklungen
ist eben nicht nur Klimaschutz sondern
zum Beispiel auch Umweltschutz und auch
hier hat der Verkehrssektor erheblichen
Nachholbedarf der Straßenbau der
verbraucht Fläche Wälder werden
abgeholzt Moore werden trockengelegt
Lebensräume von Wildtieren werden
zerschnitten deswegen haben wir auch
etwas im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
nämlich den Flächenverbrauch stark
einzudämmen und das gilt es nun in die
Arbeit der Ministerien in die Arbeit des
Verkehrsministeriums zu implementieren
und das betrifft dann zum Beispiel den
Straßen neu und Ausbau da müssen wir da
werden wir reduzieren müssen
und ganz ehrlich wenn es jetzt
da gibt es auch gar nicht so viel
Widerspruch das ist auch logisch weil
vier Fraktionen der hier versammelten
Fraktionen haben dem auch schon mal 2010
zugestimmt im Rahmen der onet wo stand
und Wachstum wachsen und Wohlstand da
ist gesagt worden wir müssen
Reduktionsziele da immer wieder
nachschauen und eben umsetzen wir müssen
weg von diesem Sonntag sehen schließlich
nachhaltig Verkehrspolitik
berücksichtigt den Gesundheitsschutz da
geht es um Lärm da geht es um Feinstaub
im Stickoxide um Ruß und da haben wir
nicht nur eine globale Verantwortung
sondern auch eine soziale und ehrlich
gesagt
und deswegen will ich das zum Schluss
vielleicht sagen wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag auch in
gleichstellungscheck und der wird auch
sich das genau anschauen das ist wichtig
und last but not least weil die FDP
anderen was ab ja wir müssen wegkommen
von dem drastischen Fehlern reizen da
haben die Kollegen von der FDP Recht und
deswegen müssen wir klimaschädliche
Subventionen
vielen Dank
stefan gelper am Ende noch mit einer
Ermahnung von Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
Marc was seine Redezeit angeht er hat
unter anderem den Klima-Check erwähnt
der im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
ist und der alle Gesetze über mit dem
alle Gesetze überprüft werden sollten
das ganze ist nach wie vor in Arbeit und
eben Wirtschaftsministerium das ohnehin
gerade gut beschäftigt ist Stefan
Brantner für die afd-fraktion
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie gibt seit 2017
die nationale Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
seit 2002 die nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie seit 2002 erst
Schröder dann Merkel jetzt Scholz mit
seiner hellbraunen Truppe meine Damen
und Herren was daraus geworden bisher
nichts ich bin jetzt der 26 Redner in
dieser Debatte 22 Mal haben wir bisher
heiße klimaschädliche altparteienluft
gehört warum frage ich mich ich sage
Ihnen warum weil sie seit 20 Jahren in
der Nachhaltigkeit herumstochern
nachhaltigkeitssumpf sich herumwuseln
und es hat zu nichts geführt der
bisherige Erfolg ihrer Nachhaltigkeit
ist sie haben Deutschland nachhaltig
geschadet sie haben Deutschland
nachhaltig ruiniert unser Deutschland
steht nachhaltig am Abgrund und zwar von
diesem Abgrund nicht mehr weit entfernt
und wenn sie nachhaltig so weitermachen
dann sind wir demnächst einen Schritt
weiter nämlich im Abgrund nachhaltig die
Armut meine Damen und Herren nimmt
rasant zu die Inflation galoppiert die
Verbraucher und Energiepreise
explodieren wir sind
verteidigungsunfähig wir sind bei
Energie Pharmazie
IT und lebensmittelabhängig vom Ausland
das ist der Erfolg ihrer
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie seit 20 Jahren
meine Leute ich sage Ihnen was wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine nachhaltige
Umsetzung des afd-programms die brauchen
wir und nichts anderes wir stehen für
wir stehen für die Existenz unseres
Deutschlands für beschlossene Grenzen
und die Beendigung der
illegalen Einwanderung wir stehen für
ein Leben dass man sich leisten kann für
Energiesicherheit und
Versorgungssicherheit für Wohlstand und
die Stärkung der Wirtschaft wir stehen
für Grundrechte für Freiheit die
demokratischen Prinzipien für
Gewaltenteilung die Freiheit der Meinung
die Demonstrationsfreiheit für eine
freie Presse und für die freie
Entfaltung der Persönlichkeit wir stehen
schlicht und ergreifend dafür unser
Deutschland unser Land zuerst vielen
Dank
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Rio Schröder Ria Schröder via Schröder
ist bildungspolitische Sprecherin der
FDP-Fraktion wenn es noch eines Beweises
für die Wichtigkeit von Bildung Bedarf
hätte dann haben sie den eben erbracht
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr verehrte
Damen und Herren auf der Tribüne Bildung
ist das Thema meiner Rede denn das
vierte nachhaltigkeitsziel das ist nicht
zufällig inklusive gerechte und
hochwertige Bildung zu gewährleisten und
Möglichkeiten des lebenslangen Lernens
für alle zu fördern Bildung schafft
Chancen für ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
und sie ist die Voraussetzung für
zukunftsweisende Wissenschaft und
Forschung dank wissenschaftlicher
Erkenntnisse kennen wir etwa den
Zusammenhang zwischen dem Ausstoß von
CO2 und dem Klimawandel dank Forschung
und Innovation können wir nachhaltige
Alternativen zu forcieren Lebensweise
entwickeln das Bundesministerium für
Bildung und Forschung treibt als
zentraler nachhaltigkeitsakteur diese
Entwicklung voran sei es mit grünem
Wasserstoff in der nationalen
wasserstoffstrategie oder bei
Zukunftstechnologien für übermorgen
beispielsweise bei der
Grundlagenforschung im Bereich der
Kernfusion bei mir liegt das Fundament
für unsere nachhaltige klimaneutrale und
souveräne Zukunft
[Applaus]
Bildung und Forschung sind die Antwort
auf die multiplen Krisen die wir derzeit
erleben Inflation ist eine der größten
Bedrohungen für den Wohlstand in unserem
Land und wenn das Ersparte auf dem Konto
oder im Sparstrumpf immer weniger wert
ist dann trifft das ganz besonders
Menschen die nur wenig Geld zur
Verfügung haben bei denen es auf jeden
Euro ankommt und gleichzeitig ist es so
dass viele Menschen gar nicht richtig
wissen wie ihnen geschieht Inflation
Finanzmarkt Bankenwesen böhmische Dörfer
für so viele in unserem Land und dafür
daher ist ökonomische Bildung
finanzielle Alphabetisierung
entscheidend meine Damen und Herren es
geht um nicht weniger als um die
Demokratisierung von elitenwissen machen
wir unser Wirtschaftssystem für alle
Menschen zugänglich in dem das Wissen
darüber bereits in der Schule
unterrichtet wird junge Menschen sollten
Ahnung haben von Aktien und ETFs sie
sollten verstehen wie man Unternehmen
gründet und wie man wie man für das
Alter vorsorgt Jungen und Mädchen in
allen Schulformen
ganz besonders für Mädchen ist die
finanzielle Bildung wichtig denn gerade
beim Thema Altersvorsorge sehen wir das
immer wieder besonders Frauen sind von
Altersarmut betroffen und es ist ein
Realität da brauchen sie die ganze Zeit
hier nicht so rumblöcken von der Seite
im Koalitionsvertrag haben wir bewusst
festgehalten dass wir Schülerfirmen als
Bestandteil von Bildung für nachhaltige
Entwicklung fördern wollen denn
ökonomische Bildung und Nachhaltigkeit
das gehört zusammen meine Damen und
Herren Bildung und Forschung machen
unsere Gesellschaft zukunftsfähig die
Menschen frei und unsere Demokratie
stark und was könnte nachhaltiger sein
Bildung Forschung und Innovation sind
drei Punkte in den
Nachhaltigkeitszielen die wiederum zur
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie gehören aber
auch nachhaltiges Wirtschaften gehört
dazu insofern passend jetzt der Beitrag
von Bernd Westphal dem
wirtschaftspolitischen Sprecher der
spd-fraktionen
haben das ist wirklich Unsinn und
Schwachsinn und ich will Ihnen ja nur
mal sagen Humboldt hat schon gesagt die
Weltanschauung derer ist sehr gefährlich
die sich die Welt nie angeschaut haben
sie sind betriebsprinzip werden mit
einer großen Mehrheit in diesem Volk nie
in der Lage sein dass sie dieses Land
regiert oder führen sie ertragen
überhaupt gar keinen Beitrag dafür wie
man Zukunft gestaltet
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Nachhaltigkeit ja merkt schon dass das
trifft im Kern weil sie hier unten nur
verbreiten zurück zum Thema
Nachhaltigkeit ist sehr wichtig und
deshalb ist es gut dass wir diese batte
heute hier im Deutschen Bundestag führen
schon im April 1961 hat Willy Brandt
gesagt in einer Rede in Bonn dass der
Himmel über dem Ruhrgebiet wieder blau
werden muss und schon damals ist erkannt
worden mit Umweltaspekten das
wirtschaftliche Erfolg nur sich
einstellen kann wenn man auch genau
diese Aspekte mit berücksichtigt damals
ist schon erkannt worden
frau Präsidentin darf ich meine Rede
fortführen Dankeschön es ist nur damit
sind tumultschleier möglich und
damals ist schon erkannt worden mit
einer Umweltbewegung des wirtschaftliche
Erfolg nur dann einstellbar ist wenn man
auch die sozialen und ökologischen
Aspekte mitberücksichtigen und deshalb
sage ich unsere Volkswirtschaft ist
nicht trotz sondern wegen hohen
Umweltschutzstandards wegen hohen
Sozialstandards wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich und das ist die Grundlage
für wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
es ist viel passiert es ist schon viel
passiert wenn man sich die Berichte der
Unternehmen anguckt und zwar nicht nur
die Finanzkennzahlen sondern die
Nachhaltigkeitsberichte die in den
letzten Jahren immer umfangreicher
geworden sind die beschreiben wo
Unternehmen sich auf den Weg gemacht
haben innovative Produkte auf den Weg zu
bringen auch Rohstoffwirtschaft so zu
organisieren in den Lieferketten dass
sie eben den hohen Ansprüchen gerecht
werden und dass wir in eine
Kreislaufwirtschaft kommen wo wir auch
Produkte aus der Industrie
wiederverwenden für neue Technologien
und das ist etwas an dem wir weiter auch
uns über Politik orientieren der
Koalitionsvertrag mit fair Fortschritt
Wagen mit mehr innovationenwagen ist
genau das Ziel dass wir das 1,5 Grad
Ziel erreichen wollen dieser
Koalitionsvertrag ist wie ein roter
Faden orientiert daran wie man diese
Ziele erreichen kann und deshalb sage
ich wir haben mit unserer Wirtschaft mit
unserem Mittelstand und Industrie nicht
das Problem sondern die Lösung für
globale Herausforderungen gerade aus der
Industrie gerade aus den Laboren aus den
Werkstätten verbunden mit Universitäten
und dieses innovative Umfeld wird dazu
führen dass wir neue
Exportmöglichkeiten entwickeln globale
Märkte erschließen für Produkte aus
deutschen Produktionen und das wird auch
helfen diese Klimaziele zu erreichen
wenn man sich mal anguckt wie wir
Investitionen gestalten ist es
sicherlich notwendig auch staatlich zu
unterstützen viele Programme Tim und
andere aus dem Wirtschaftsministerium
ermuntern ja gerade den Mittelstand
diese Innovationen nach vorne zu bringen
aber ich sage auch die Rahmenbedingungen
für private Investitionen müssen wir
verbessern auch in die Infrastruktur
unseres Landes wir müssen moderner
werden im Gesundheitswesen in der
Infrastruktur das was erneuerbare
Energien angeht Wasserstofftechnologie
aber auch die Glasfasernetze das wird
die Zukunft sein auf der sich
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung gut
entfalten kann
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren Willy
Brandt hat auch gesagt dass wir als
reiche Länder eine Verantwortung haben
auch gegenüber der südlichen Halbkugel
in einem Ländern Schwellenländern und
das was Willy Brandt mit Olaf Palm auf
den Weg gebracht hat den Nord-Süd-Dialog
das ist auch getragen von einer
Verantwortung eines reichen Landes wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass wir die
sozialen Aspekte global verankern es
kann nicht sein dass wir mit Hunger mit
Armut mit Kindersterblichkeit des
zulassen wie andere Menschen in anderen
Regionen leben müssen letzter Satz frau
Präsidentin ich finde auch die sozialen
Aspekte müssen wir hier in Deutschland
in den Betrieben uns noch mal angucken
wie wir Mitbestimmung beteiligen zum
Schluss Verteidigung der Belegschaft
auch erweitern können auch in den Themen
der Nachhaltigkeit des Klima vielen Dank
während Westphal wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion in der Debatte
über die deutsche
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie nächster Redner
Andreas Lenz cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Ziel einer
nachhaltigen Entwicklung ist gerade auch
jetzt wichtig und schaut mal auf die
Welt dann bestätigt sich doch diese
Einschätzung und insofern können die 14
Nachhaltigkeitsziele die auf Ebene der
Vereinten Nationen beschlossen wurden
beispielsweise keine Armut Ziel eins
Ziel zwei kein Hunger gute Bildung C4
Gleichberechtigung der Geschlechter C5
bis hin zufrieden Gerechtigkeit starke
Institutionen gerade jetzt und auch im
internationalen Kontext nicht stark
genug betont werden gerade jetzt ist
eine nachhaltige Entwicklung wichtig
meine Damen und Herren und jetzt wissen
wir gerade in Krisenzeiten spricht man
nicht so gerne über Themen wie
Nachhaltigkeit weil an mancher glaubt
das wäre jetzt nicht so wichtig es ist
auch übrigens schade dass die zuständige
Staatsministerin niklewski der Debatte
nicht mehr beiwohnt aber ich möchte aber
ich möchte ganz klar sagen dass
Gegenteil ist doch der Fall es geht bei
Fragen einer nachhaltigen Entwicklung
auch darum Krisen in der Zukunft zu
verhindern viele schwerwiegende Krisen
der heutigen Zeit sind sogenannte
systemische Krisen Pandemien Klimakrise
Finanzkrisen Krisen der
Energieversorgung Stichwort Gefahren
eines Blackouts lieferkettenprobleme
internationale Abhängigkeiten und so
weiter und das heißt es sind immer
anfällige Gesamtsysteme oft sehr
verwundbar oft auch im globalen Kontext
stehen und deshalb bedeutet nachhaltige
Entwicklung immer auch ein mehr an
Resilienz an mehr an
Widerstandsfähigkeit ins System damit
auch ein mehr an Souveränität und zwar
in jedem Bereich bei der
Nahrungsmittelversorgung bei der Frage
der medizinischen Erzeugnisse aber auch
bei der Frage von gewissen
einsatzprodukten für unsere Wirtschaft
bei der Frage von Mikrochips bei
Lieferketten mehr Widerstandsfähigkeit
auch durch stabile Staatsfinanzen und
damit mehr Stabilität für die sozialen
Sicherungssysteme und natürlich auch
mehr
Generationengerechtigkeit und für diese
Stabilität für diese
Widerstandsfähigkeit stehen wir als
Union und das haben wir in unserem
Antrag auch sehr deutlich gemacht um das
klar zu sagen
wir stehen zu einer nachhaltigen
heimischen Landwirtschaft die wiederum
für Ernährungssicherheit steht und dazu
beiträgt und wir wollen im Kontext der
Ernährungssicherheit übrigens explizit
rechts und Sicherheiten bei der
kostenlosen Weitergabe von Lebensmitteln
abbauen es ist ja nach wie vor ein
Skandal das 11 Millionen Tonnen
Lebensmittel in den im Abfall landen das
pro Person 78 Kilogramm Nahrungsmittel
im Abfall landen und da muss weiter
dagegen gearbeitet werden wir stehen
außerdem für Regionalität für Lokalität
wir brauchen eine neue Balance zwischen
Internationalität der internationalen
Arbeitsteilung die in keiner Weise in
Frage zu stellen ist und Regionalität
Produkte aus der Region sind ein
Mega-Trend mit vielen Chancen mit vielen
Wertschöpfungsmöglichkeiten und wir
haben in einer Aktion am Dienstag als
Unionsfraktion eben auch diese Vielfalt
aus den Regionen sehr gut dargestellt
sie werden außerdem dazu beitragen diese
regional Produkte tragen dazu bei
Transportwege zu sparen zum Nutzen aller
wir werden Regionalität regionale
Produkte weiter stärken meine Damen und
Herren
und gerade im Moment zeigt sich doch
auch an vielen Stellen wir können nur
helfen auch international wenn wir
wirtschaftlich stark sind wenn wir
leistungsfähig bleiben wir können auch
nur dann technologischen Transfer
übrigens leisten wenn unsere Technologie
wenn wir unsere Technologien auch im
eigenen Land anwenden und wenn sie dann
auch entsprechend entsprechend
erfolgreich international sind wie
wichtig die ökonomische Dimension ist
das erleben wir doch gerade jetzt auch
im Sinne der Energieversorgung wir
brauchen hier auch alle Dimensionen wir
brauchen natürlich die ökologische
Dimension wir brauchen mehr Erneuerbaren
wir müssen auch systemisch denken wir
brauchen Versorgungssicherheit wir
brauchen aber auch bei der
Energieversorgung die wirtschaftliche
die ökonomische Perspektive die
Dimension dass wir auch entsprechend
wettbewerbsfähige Preise brauchen für
unsere Wirtschaft und wir müssen
natürlich auch die soziale Dimension
entsprechend berücksichtigen dass sich
jeder auch die Energieversorgung
entsprechend leisten muss wir brauchen
diese Voraussetzungen sonst dro einer
Dimension entsprechend auch die
ökonomische im gesamten in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen zu werden und
verschwindet die Industrie verschwindet
das produzierende Gewerbe in Deutschland
dann gibt es auch nichts mehr zu
transformieren hin zu einer
klimaneutralen Wirtschaft das müssen wir
immer auch entsprechend im Hinterkopf
haben
verschwindet die Industrie aus
Deutschland das sind aber die Emissionen
nicht weg die Emissionen finden dann an
anderen Orten der Welt statt und das ist
eben gerade nicht nachhaltig manchmal
kann man sich den Begriff der
Nachhaltigkeit übrigens auch nähern wenn
man davon ausgeht was nicht nachhaltig
ist ein Beispiel das eben zeigt dass
Nachhaltigkeit nur funktioniert wenn
alle Dimensionen entsprechend
berücksichtigt werden und das
Nachhaltigkeit immer auch immer auch
eine globale Perspektive hat der Weg zu
einer nachhaltigen Entwicklung des lang
wir sind schon einen guten Weg gegangen
und es ist aus meiner aus unserer Sicht
alle Mühe wert diesen Weg entsprechend
weiterzugehen und dabei müssen wir auch
immer wissen dass der Weg hin zu einer
nachhaltigen Entwicklung auch immer ein
Stück ein Weg hinzu einem Mehr an
Nachhaltigkeit eben auch entsprechend
ist und nicht entsprechend in einem Ziel
dann die Erfüllung findet sondern auch
sich entsprechend in diesen Prozess
wiederfindet in diesem Sinne herzlichen
Dank
Andreas Lenz war das aus der
Unionsfraktion und ihm wird jetzt folgen
Caroline Otto sie ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Wohnen statt Entwicklung
Bauwesen und Kommunen und sie ahnen es
auch das ein wichtiger Aspekt beim Thema
Nachhaltigkeit und falls ich jetzt aus
Versehen Ortho gesagt habe das ist
falsch
wäre richtig gewesen
es geht um nicht weniger als eine Welt
die Zukunft hat
die Klimakrise das tatsächliche an die
Wand fahren unserer Lebensgrundlage das
kann einem im Plenardebatten vielleicht
reichlich abstrakt verkommen aber ein
Jahr nach der Katastrophe im artal nach
einem Hitzesommer mit krasser Dürre vom
Schwarzwald bis nach Brandenburg
wenn Sie das so sehen ich fand es ganz
schön warm mit den aktuellen Bildern aus
Pakistan es muss doch jetzt überall klar
geworden sein was die Abhängigkeit von
fossilen Energien für unsere
Gesellschaft bedeutet eine Abhängigkeit
die just in diesem Moment als Waffe
gegen uns gerichtet wird die Antwort auf
die Vielzahl dieser Krisen mit denen wir
gerade umgehen müssen die darf nicht der
fossile Rollback sein
der Kampf für eine Welt die Zukunft hat
beginnt vor Ort und er ist
entschlossener zu führen denn je wir
müssen jetzt vor Ort investieren in der
aktuellen Situation auf die
Schuldenbremse zu pochen das ist
gefährlich
der nächste wichtige Schritt die
wärmewende die findet vor Ort statt und
braucht die Bereitschaft des Bundes da
substanziellen Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen
den wärmeenergieverbrauch schnell zu
senken das ist das Gebot der Stunde
Städte und Gemeinden arbeiten mit
niedrigschwelligen Maßnahmen schon jetzt
daran und heben ein Effizienzpotenzial
von 20%. damit wir mittel und
langfristig den wärmeenergieverbrauch
senken ist es entscheidend dass wir
energetische Gebäudesanierung verstärkt
fördern mit dem Gebäude Energiegesetz
wird außerdem dafür gesorgt dass 65%
erneuerbare erneuerbare Wärme und der
KFW 40 Standard für den Neubau zum
Standardwerten
damit wir sicherstellen dass alle
Haushalte eine Alternative zu fossil
betriebenen Heizsystemen haben
brauchen wir die kommunale wärmeplanung
hier füllen wir die wärmewende vor Ort
mit leben
mit der kommunalen wärmeplanung bringen
wir ein Projekt des Koalitionsvertrages
auf dem Weg das zentrale ist für die
Bewältigung der wärmebände wir brauchen
vor Ort die Mittel und das Personal ein
guter Antworten gemeinsam mit den
Menschen entwickeln zu können bis und
das Dorf hinein aus dem ich komme
brauchen wir gute Lösungen
flächendeckend und verschränkt mit dem
systementwicklungsplan des
Wirtschaftsministeriums wir brauchen die
Städte und Gemeinden für eine Welt die
Zukunft hat brauchen wir starke Kommunen
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort dr
Dirk Spaniel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen
meine Uhr läuft nicht
so ist gut so also fange ich schon mal
an ja meine Damen und Herren wir haben
die Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte hier diese
Nachhaltigkeitsdebatte die wir jetzt
hier stundenlang hören zeigt uns vor
allen Dingen dass sie nicht interessiert
sind an echten Lösungen sondern vor
allen Dingen daran interessiert sind
hier phrasenreden zu halten und Menschen
zu beeindrucken mit leeren
Versprechungen und jetzt komme ich mal
konkret was haben sie für Gesetze
gemacht sie haben ja die Gesetze gemacht
die letzten Jahre nicht wir sie haben
ein Gesetz gemacht nachdem ein im
Verkehrssektor jetzt mal davon zu reden
geht es ja immer um die Reduktion von
CO2-Emissionen und das ist ihr größtes
Ziel und sie haben ein Gesetz gemacht
mit dem Elektroautos die mit Kohlestrom
geladen werden
ein CO2-Ausstoß erzeugen der doppelt so
groß ist wie der von heutigen diese
betriebenen Kraftfahrzeugen doppelt so
groß das können wir hier machen das ist
ihr Gesetz dass sie gemacht haben auf
europäischer Ebene dagegen wollen Sie
verhindern dass die Besitzer von
verbrennungsmotorischen Autos mit
co2-neutralem Sprit und gar keine
Emissionen erzeugen dass diese als
nachhaltig eingestuft werden das ist
ihre konkrete Gesetzgebung und das ist
nicht nachhaltig das ist einfach nur
Unsinn und das führt auch dazu dass die
Arbeitsplätze in unserem Land verloren
gehen und dass die Gleichheit in unserem
Land die wir ja immer anstreben dass
manche Menschen sich Mobilität mit Autos
leisten können und andere nicht dass die
verloren geht es wird in unserem Land
dazu führen dass nur noch sehr wenige
Menschen sich Mobilität leisten können
weil viele nämlich auch gar kein
Arbeitsplatz mehr haben weil die
Elektroautos die sie die sie so gerne
wollen die kommen gar nicht aus
Deutschland
und das ist ganz anders als die
Nachhaltigkeit die wir uns als Partei
vorstellen wir wollen auch
Nachhaltigkeit wir wollen genau die 17
Development Goals die sie auch haben
aber mit anderen Methoden wir wollen
nicht ihre Phrasen nachziehen wir wollen
dass die Menschen in unserem Land alle
die Möglichkeit haben einen Arbeitsplatz
zu haben mit dem sie ordentlich Geld
verdienen und dass sie auch alle die
Möglichkeit haben frei zu entscheiden
was für ein Auto Sie fahren das ist
unser Verständnis von Nachhaltigkeit und
davon habe ich hier heute nur von den
Redners unser Fraktion etwas gehört von
ihnen habe ich davon nichts gehört
und dann ist auch die Uhr von Dirk
Spaniel abgelaufen wenn auch mit
Verspätung gestartet jetzt kommen wir zu
Nils Gründer FDP-Fraktion erst seit
August im Parlament seinen Vorgänger
eben Parlament in der FDP-Fraktion war
Thomas Sattelberger der wegen
Krankheitsfällen in seinem näheren
persönlichen Umfeld sich zurückgezogen
hat aus dem Bundestag jetzt also Nils
Gründer einer recht neu dabei
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele der Vereinten
Nationen sind wohl den meisten hier ein
Begriff sie sind Grundlage der deutschen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie mit ihren sechs
Prinzipien Kompass für nachhaltiges
Leben und die wohl größte
peacekeeping-mission des 21 jahrhunderts
wie spürbar die Konsequenzen von
globalen Konflikten in Deutschland sind
erleben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger jeden
Tag ob an der Kasse im Supermarkt oder
beim Tanken an der Zapfsäule
um diese Auswirkungen zu mindern spielt
Nachhaltigkeit eine entscheidende Rolle
nehmen wir unsere Verantwortung die wir
als viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
haben war und lassen Nachhaltigkeit als
elementaren Bestandteil der globalen
Sicherheitsarchitektur mit in unserer
Handeln einfließen
konkret denke ich dabei an folgende
Punkte
genau wie Freiheit Demokratie und
Menschenrechte ein unumstrittener Aspekt
der deutschen sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik sind sollte
Nachhaltigkeit auch Teil dieses
Selbstverständnisses sein denn neben der
dringend notwendigen materiellen
Ausstattung trägt beispielsweise auch
die Prävention von Fluchtursachen wie
Dürren und Überflutungen zu
Konfliktvermeidung bei
der Stellenwert den Nachhaltigkeit in
der internationalen Gemeinschaft bereits
auf dem Papier genießt muss endlich auch
die den praktischen Umsetzungen gerecht
werden denn Nachhaltigkeit ist eine
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe die wir nur in
Kooperation mit allen Staaten umsetzen
können
und das ist keine Gedankensprünge
braucht um Nachhaltigkeit um
Sicherheitspolitik zusammenzudenken
zeigen vielerlei Beispiele sei es die
Auswirkungen von unter anderem
Ernteausfällen auf das politische Klima
in Syrien im Vorfeld des Bürgerkriegs
sei es Länder unabhängiger von endlichen
Ressourcen zu machen die die Gefahr von
Konflikten Bergen wie wir sie derzeit
unter anderem im Südsudan beobachten das
bundeswehrmandat für die UN-Mission im
Kooperation mit Schuba im Südsudan
Südsudan zeigt wie greifbar und
unmittelbar die Konsequenzen auch für
deutsche Staatsbürgerinnen und
Staatsbürger sind
wie meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute
bereits ausgeführt haben spielt die
Finanzierung der benannten Projekte
einen entscheidende Rolle ich möchte
eindringlich darauf hinweisen dass ein
Entwicklungshilfen für mehr
Nachhaltigkeit eben keine Spenden sind
sie sind Investitionen eine friedliche
Zukunft
außerdem sind sie Teil der Verantwortung
eines Landes das ein globalen
Führungsanspruch äußert
Entwicklungsgelder die in un
Nachhaltigkeitsziele fließend sind
Investitionen eine nachhaltige Zukunft
und in eine globale und stabile
Sicherheitsarchitektur vielen Dank
Nils Gründer für die FDP-Fraktion und
ihm wird jetzt folgen Dorothee Martin
aus der SPD-Fraktion sie ist
verkehrspolitische Sprecherin das Thema
Verkehr ist ja wiederholt schon
angesprochen worden im Zusammenhang mit
Nachhaltigkeit und das ist ja auch der
Sektor wo was ist die CO2 Reduzierung
angeht nach wie vor die größten Defizite
gibt
Gesetz zur Rede von der AFD sie hat
einfach noch mal dieses völlig düstere
und menschenverachtende Bild gezeigt
dass ihre Politik prägt dass auch von
einer fachfremdheit nur so
gekennzeichnet ist nur ein Beispiel in
der Lausitz es stehen jetzt gerade noch
mal tausend neue Jobs durch neue
Batteriezellen Produktion das Verleugnen
Sie dass missachten Sie dass es Ihre
reine Angst machen für die Menschen
ihrem Land das ist unseriös das ist
verabreckend
wenn sie weiter pöbeln wollen gehen Sie
einfach raus hier ist kein Raum dafür
jetzt aber zu meiner Rede lieber
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Mobilität und Nachhaltigkeit das gehört
für uns Sozialdemokratien
Sozialdemokraten untrennbar zusammen und
unser Koalitionsvertrag ist da ganz klar
wir wollen die 2020er Jahre zu einem
Aufbruch in der mobilitätspolitik Nutzen
und eine nachhaltige eine effiziente
eine barrierefreie intelligente und
bezahlbare Mobilität für alle möglich
machen und dafür setzen wir auf Ausbau
von der Elektromobilität auf Stärkung
von Schiene von Wasserstraße Ausbau von
Radwegen vernetzte Angebote im ÖPNV und
vieles mehr um nur einige Beispiele zu
nennen und ein Prinzip in der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie das ist
nachhaltiges Bauen und Verkehrswende und
diese Verknüpfung finde ich gerade auch
bei Verkehrsprojekten unglaublich
wichtig denn auch da müssen wir bereits
in der Bau und Planungsphase
Nachhaltigkeit und Klimaschutz deutlich
priorisieren und dazu ein Beispiel aus
meiner Heimatstadt in Hamburg wird
derzeit eine neue U-Bahn quer durch die
ganze Stadt gebaut und die neue U5 wird
die klimaschonende U-Bahn in Deutschland
denn schon beim Bau sollen Emissionen so
weit wie möglich verringert werden nach
konventioneller Bauweise wurde errechnet
im stünde ein CO2-Ausstoß von fast drei
Millionen Tonnen aber dank einer unter
co2-aspekten eben völlig neuen
optimierten Planungen können diese
Emissionen im Bau schon um 70 Prozent
verringert werden und mit der neuen
U-Bahn werden dann nach Fertigstellung
täglich rund bislang 290.000 gefahrene
Kilometer PKW Kilometer eingespart
täglich eingespart das spart Emissionen
das entlastet unsere Straßen und das
reduziert auch Lärm für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und dieses Vorhaben das zeigt
ganz beispielhaft mit einem modernen mit
einem nachhaltigen ange schaffen wir den
Umstieg vom Auto auf den ÖPNV meine
Damen und Herren
für uns als SPD ist wichtig nachhaltige
Mobilität bedeutet Teilhabe und ist
damit auch eine Frage der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit und damit diese Teilhabe
auf dem Land eben genauso möglich ist
wie in der Stadt brauchen wir allerorts
Ausbau von Bus und Bahn und dabei werden
auch ganz neue Konzepte und Innovationen
und auch Reaktivierung von stillgelegter
Infrastruktur helfen um ein Beispiel zu
nennen ich habe mir im Frühjahr mit
unserem Kollegen Jürgen berghan zusammen
ein ganz tolles Projekt in Ostwestfalen
angeguckt das monocap wo Forscher einen
autonomen fahrendes Mobilitätsangebot
entwickeln das eben auch aus
stillgelegten Bahnstrecken eingesetzt
werden kann und gerade solche
Innovationen müssen wir weiter
unterstützen und fördern
aber Nachhaltigkeit und Mobilität die
haben auch mit Stadtentwicklungen auch
mit Aufteilung des Straßenraums zu tun
und wenn man es mal die aktuellen
Regelungen in der Straßenverkehrsordnung
Straßenverkehrsgesetz angucken die sind
immer noch auf die autogerechte Stadt
ausgelegt das werden wir ändern indem
wir die Regelungen
die Regelungen mit den Zielen des
Klimaschutzes der Gesundheit und auch
der städtebaulichen Entwicklung
vereinbaren verankern dort deutlich mehr
Fokus draufsetzen dort den Kommunen auch
deutlich mehr Handlungsspielraum geben
und wir wissen alle die
Herausforderungen gerade zu erreichen
und kommen zum Klimaziele im
Verkehrsbereich die sind riesig aber wir
können sie bewältigen gemeinsam anpacken
jetzt umsetzen mit voller Kraft voraus
vielen Dank
Dorothee Martin verkehrspolitische
Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion und wir
beobachten ein klein wenig ob Yvonne
Markt was die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
sich vielleicht noch mal äußert zum
debattenverhalten zumindest auf einem
Teil hier eben Plenum das doch auffällig
geworden ist in der letzten Zeit wir
schauen aber erst auf die nächsten
Redner erfolgreich ist aus der
Unionsfraktion und Mitglied im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung
zumindest die meisten von uns als
erfrischend wie wir uns heute in dieser
Debatte mit den verschiedensten
Ausprägungen und Spielarten dieses uns
alle betreffenden Themas
auseinandersetzen es wurde in diesem
Zusammenhang bereits mehrfach
angesprochen vielleicht wäre ein etwas
stärker ausgeprägter Rahmen für dieses
doch so zukunftsträchtige Thema auch ein
starkes Signal gewesen ein Signal auch
wie wichtig das Thema der Ampel
Bundesregierung ist früher gab es
nämlich mal wir haben das schon gehört
auch unter Beteiligung der Union
eingeführt mehrere
Nachhaltigkeitstage im Parlament
aber lassen Sie mich gerne auf einen
konkreten Bereich zu sprechen kommen der
im Bezug zur Nachhaltigkeit insbesondere
aus meiner Sicht als zuständiger
Berichterstatter eine ganz bedeutende
Rolle spielt nämlich der
Verbraucherschutz
Nachhaltigkeit und Verbraucherschutz
gehen nämlich in der Tat oftmals Hand in
Hand beispielsweise bei der Lebensdauer
von Produkten ich glaube wir haben das
alles schon mal erlebt dass bei
technikgeräten wie im Handys oder bei
Laptops manchmal auf gerade zu magische
aber eben auch auf frappierend
auffällige Weise nach einem bestimmten
Zeit am besten ungefähr nach Ablauf von
Gewährleistung und Garantie diese
beginnen nicht mehr richtig zu
funktionieren
nachhaltig ist das nur für die Bilanz
der Produzenten der teure Reparaturen
oder in der Regel sogar ein Neukauf
anfallen
dazu passt natürlich auch besonders dass
er vielen Ebenen geforderte und auch im
Koalitionsvertrag zu findende Recht auf
Reparatur dieses gerade auch mit Blick
auf die umfangreichen Herausforderungen
den wir uns aktuell gegenüberstehen ein
wichtiger Finger zeigt wir müssen weg
von der
Wegwerfmentalität denn in der Regel ist
Schrott eben nicht das was wir
umgangssprachlich damit bezeichnen
sondern Schrott insbesondere der
Elektroschrott ist ein richtig
wertvolles Gut oft voll mit Rohstoffen
die wiederverwertet gehören hier ergeben
sich riesige Chancen für den Schutz den
Erhalt und die Wiederverwendung von
Rohstoffen und Materialien das ist
Nachhaltigkeit in ihrer reinsten Form
aber bei allen ambitionierten Zielen die
wir uns in Deutschland setzen wir müssen
uns auch klar sein dass wir auf globaler
Ebene viel zu klein und zu unbedeutend
sind als das wir das Ruder alleine
herumreisen könnten
selbstverständlich kann und muss
Deutschland Vorreiter sein aber wenn die
USA China oder zwischen auch Indien
nicht mitziehen dann bewegt sich global
betrachtet eben fast nichts und wir
müssen leider feststellen dass die
weltweiten EU Nachhaltigkeitszielen noch
viel schwieriger und sehr zu erreichen
sind als das im eigenen Land schon der
Fall ist dabei gibt es eigentlich den
allergrößten Nachholbedarf
eingriffiges Beispiel wir verbieten bei
uns plastikstrohhalme während in anderen
Teilen der Welt mehr Plastiktüten als
Fische in den Flüssen schwimmen oder
nehmen wir den Abbau seltener Erden und
andere Rohstoffe unter Menschen
unwürdigen Verhältnissen in anderen
Teilen dieser Erde
Chemieanlagen die giftige Stoffe in
Gewässer einleiten oder die gewaltigen
Eingriffe in die Regenwälder unserer
Erde oftmals für Produkte die hier bei
uns auch aus Unwissenheit ganz
selbstverständlich und ohne mit der
Wimper zu zucken konsumiert werden
Nachhaltigkeit fängt eben auch schon
beim Verbraucherverhalten und damit auch
bei der Verbraucher Information an
auch deshalb dürfen wir unsere
Produktionsstandort der weltweit die
höchsten Standards der drei Säulen der
Nachhaltigkeit aufweist ökonomisch
ökologisch und sozial nicht aus dem Land
treiben nicht nachhaltig ist es nämlich
die Produktion von Industriegütern in
einem Land mit hohen Standards und
moderner Technik in andere Teile der
Welt zu verlagern in den oftmals keine
solchen Vorgaben eingehalten werden
müssen ist es denn nicht beispielsweise
absurd wenn bei der Produktion
beispielsweise in Südostasien das
vielfache an CO2 entsteht als wenn wir
das entsprechende Produkt selbst
herstellen würden vom ökologischen
Fußabdruck der Lieferwege einmal ganz
abgesehen wem ist dir geholfen dem
Weltklima mit Sicherheit nicht und auch
nicht den Menschen die oft unter
schlechtesten Arbeitsbedingungen und
miserabler Bezahlung die Luxusgüter des
Westens herstellen
mir persönlich sind die
nachhaltigkeitsdiskussionen auch hier im
Hause oftmals viel zu akademisch und zu
theoretisch ich würde mir mehr
politisches und gesellschaftliches
Handeln anhand der
nachhaltigkeitsgrundsätze wünschen so
wie wir das auch im parlamentarischen
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung des
Deutschen Bundestages fördern mit Blick
auf die kommenden Generationen denen wir
verpflichtet sind wurde Nachhaltigkeit
bereits treffend mit nur einem Satz
beschrieben was immer du tust das tue
klug und bedenke das Ende vielen Dank
mehr handeln als reden fordert nicht nur
dieses Mitglied des parlamentarischen
Beirats für nachhaltige Entwicklung das
war Volker Meierei sondern auch manche
andere die wir in dieser Debatte hier
schon gehört haben am Pult ist jetzt
Sandra detzer für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen sie ist mitgegeben
Wirtschafts- und im Finanzausschuss
insgesamt vier nachhaltigkeitsjahre und
ich glaube das ist der Stern unter dem
wir unsere Arbeit steht
meine lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Frage der ob der Nachhaltigkeit ist
zum Glück längs geklärt es geht längst
um die Frage des wie und je schneller
wir konkret werden können desto besser
und als Abgeordnete wunderbaren
Wahlkreis Ludwigsburg in der schönen
Region Stuttgart sage ich aus voller
Überzeugung Geschwindigkeit erreichen
wir dann wenn wir Nachhaltigkeit noch
mehr zum Geschäftsmodell machen wenn wir
unternehmen und Beschäftigten die
Planungssicherheit geben und die
richtigen Rahmenbedingungen damit sie
ihre Innovationskraft für Nachhaltigkeit
einsetzen können dann werden eben jeden
Tag zig Millionen Einzelentscheidungen
in den Betrieben zugunsten der
Nachhaltigkeit getroffen und dann sind
wir auch so schnell wie wir sein müssen
um die Ökonomie und die Ökologie zu
versöhnen
und die gute Nachricht ist Unternehmen
und ihre Beschäftigten haben sich eben
längst auf den Weg gemacht und
Mittelstand und Handwerk sehen
Nachhaltigkeit sehen regionale
Wirtschaftskreisläufe längst als Chance
in meiner Region beispielsweise gibt es
einen großen recycling-betonhersteller
die Firma fees der verdient jetzt schon
mehr Geld mit Recyclingbaustoffen als
mit primärer Rohstoffen und der schon
schon jetzt eben die natürlichen
Ressourcen damit und es gleichzeitig ein
wichtiger Akteur auf den Markt und jetzt
sagt der er wird diese Sparte Abriss
auch weiter ausbauen weil natürlich in
dem Bereich unheimlich viel Musik drin
ist er hofft auf die Ampel erwartet auf
diese richtigen Rahmenbedingungen und
genau die wollen wir eben geben
wir werden wie geht es konkret das wurde
oft angesprochen und es ist ganz genau
richtig ich glaube wir müssen am
konkreten am wie der Umsetzung jetzt
arbeiten wie wollen wir das machen wir
definieren Abfälle selbstverständlich
als Rohstoffe und werden so
Stoffkreisläufe schließen wir unter uns
schützen Unternehmen ihre Lieferketten
zu stabilisieren dann sehr wichtiges
Thema momentan
sekundärmaterialien mehr einzusetzen und
eben diese Kreisläufe gerade auch
regional zu schließen und wir machen
zirkuläres Wirtschaften attraktiver um
wegzukommen von der linearen
Wegwerfgesellschaft
Nachhaltigkeit ganz klar es ist oft
angesprochen worden schont unseren
Planeten und sichert die
Handlungsfreiheit auch künftiger
Generationen aber sie macht eben auch
unsere Wirtschaft wettbewerbsfähiger
unresellierenter und wir wollen globaler
Vorreiter sein auf dem Weg zu
nachhaltigem Wohlstand und wenn wir eben
weltweit viele Nachahmerinnen finden
wollen dann ist das der Schlüssel für
die Geschwindigkeit gerade in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten herzlichen Dank
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Martin Reichert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik ist wie so vieles
was Bundesregierung fabrizierten links
totalitär die Grundlage aller
Nachhaltigkeit nämlich der Erhalt des
staatsvolks findet in ihr keinen Platz
in den letzten 50 Jahren starben in
Deutschland 6,1 Millionen Menschen mehr
als geboren wurden
230.000 allein 2021 über sechs Millionen
Menschen ohne Kriege nur durch
familienfeindliche Politik meine Damen
und Herren
sechs Millionen Menschen die heute als
Fachkräfte zur Erhaltung unseres
rentengesundheits- und Sozialsystems
fehlen eine Entwicklung die sich in den
kommenden Jahrzehnten noch verstärkt und
sich in jährlichen sterbeüberschüssen
von 300.000 und mehr fortsetzt was zum
endgültigen Kollaps der Sozialsysteme
führt und in letzter Konsequenz das
Aussterben des deutschen Volkes zur
Folge hat kein Wort zur Abwendung dieser
demografischen Katastrophe in den
nachhaltigkeitsprinzipien keine
Informationskampagnen zu den
verheerenden Folgen dieser Entwicklung
kein Konzept um diese Katastrophe
explizit abzuwenden nichts die Kosten
der Energiewende werden bis 2050
zwischen 1 und 3 Billionen Euro
geschätzt investieren Sie dieses Geld in
eine geburtenfördernde Politik die die
Lücke zwischen dem Kinderwunsch junger
Menschen und der tatsächlichen
Geburtenzahl schließt und dabei auch
noch die Kinder und familienarmut
tatsächlich bekämpft und dann eine
bevölkerungsbilanz ohne
sterbeüberschüsse ermöglicht
sie
lassen das deutsche Volk tatenlos
verändern sie reden von Nachhaltigkeit
und Artenschutz und lassen eines der
größten Kulturvölker der Weltgeschichte